in this course you will learn all about
natural language processing and how to
apply it to real world problems using
the spacey library dr mattingly is
extremely knowledgeable in this area and
he's an excellent teacher
hi and welcome to this video my name is
dr william mattingly and i specialize in
multilingual natural language processing
i come to nlp from a humanities
perspective i have my phd in medieval
history but i use spacey on a regular
basis to do all of my nlp needs so what
you're going to get out of this video
over the next few hours is a basic
understanding of what natural language
processing is or nlp
and also how to apply it to domain
specific problems
or problems that exist within your own
area of expertise i happen to use this
all the time to analyze historical
documents or financial documents for my
own personal investments over the next
few hours you're going to learn a lot
about nlp language as a whole and most
importantly the spacey library
i like the spacey library because it's
easy to use and easy to also implement
really kind of general solutions to
general problems with the off-the-shelf
models that are already available to you
i'm going to walk you through in part
one of this video series how to get the
most out of spacey with these
off-the-shelf features
in part two we're going to start
tackling some of the features that don't
exist in off-the-shelf models and i'm
going to show you how to use rules-based
pipes or components in spacey to
actually solve domain-specific problems
in your own area from the entity ruler
to the matcher to actually injecting
robust complex regular expression or
regex patterns in a custom spacey
component that doesn't actually exist at
the moment
i'm going to be showing you all that in
part two so that in part three we can
take the lessons that we learned in part
one and part two and actually apply them
to solve a very kind of common problem
that exists in nlp and that is
information extraction from financial
documents so finding things that are of
relevance such as stocks
markets indexes and stock exchanges if
you join me over the next few hours you
will leave this lesson with a good
understand understanding of spacey and
also a good understanding of kind of the
off-the-shelf components that are there
and a way to take the off-the-shelf
components and apply them to your own
domain
if you also join me in this video and
you like it please let me know in the
comments down below because i am
interested in making a second part to
this video that will explore not only
the rules based aspects of spacey but
the machine learning based aspects of
spacey so teaching you how to train your
own models to do your own things such as
training a dependency parser training a
named entity recognizer things like this
which are not covered in this video
nevertheless if you join me for this one
and you like it you will find part two
much easier to understand so sit back
relax and let's jump into what nlp is
what kind of things you can do with nlp
such as information extraction and what
the spacey library is and how this
course will be laid out if you like this
video also consider subscribing to my
channel python tutorials for digital
humanities which is linked in the
description down below
even if you're not a digital humanist
like me you will find these python
tutorials useful because they take
python and make it accessible to
students of all levels specifically
those who are beginners i walk you
through not only the basics of python
but also i walk you through step by step
some of the more common libraries that
you need a lot of the channel deals with
texts or text based problems but other
content deals with things like machine
learning and image classification and
ocr all in python
so before we begin with spacey i think
we should spend a little bit of time
talking about what nlp or natural
language processing actually is
natural language processing is the
process by which we try to get a
computer system to understand and parse
and extract
human language often times with raw text
there are a couple different areas of
natural language processing there is
named entity recognition part of speech
tagging syntactic parsing text
categorization also known as text
classification co-reference resolution
machine translation adjacent to nlp is
another kind of computational
linguistics field called natural
language understanding or nlu this is
where we train computer systems to do
things like relation extraction semantic
parsing question and answering this is
where bots really kind of come into play
summarization sentiment analysis and
paraphrasing
nlp and nlu are used by a wide array of
industries from finance industry all the
way through to law
and academia with researchers trying to
do
information extraction from texts within
nlp there's a couple different
applications the first and probably the
most important is information extraction
this is the process by which we try to
get a computer system to extract
information that we find
relevant to our own research or needs so
for example as we're going to see in
part three of this video when we apply
spacey to the financial sector a person
interested in finances might need nlp to
go through and extract things like
company names stocks indexes things that
are referenced within maybe news
articles from reuters to new york times
to wall street journal
this is an example of using nlp to
extract information a good way to think
about nlp's application in this area is
it takes in some unstructured data in
this case raw text and extracts
structured data from it or metadata so
it finds the things that you want it to
find and extracts them for you now while
there's ways to do this with gusseteers
and list matching using an nlp framework
like spacey which i'll talk about in
just a second has certain advantages the
main one being that you can use and
leverage things that have been parsed
syntactically or semantically so things
like the part of speech of a word things
like its dependencies things like its
co-reference these are things that the
spacey framework allow for you to do off
the shelf and also train into machine
learning models and work into pipelines
with rules
so that's kind of one aspect of nlp and
one way it's used another way it's used
is to read in data and classify it this
is known as text categorization and we
see that on the left hand side of this
image text categorization or text
classification we conclude in this
sentiment analysis for the most part as
well is a way we take information into a
computer system again unstructured data
a raw text and we classify it in some
way
you've actually seen this at work for
many decades now with
spam detection spam detection is nearly
perfect it needs to be continually
updated but for the most part it is a
solved problem the reason why you have
emails that automatically go to your
spam folder is because there's a machine
learning model that sits on the
background of your the back end of your
email server and what it does is it
actually looks at the emails it sees if
it fits the pattern for what it's seen
as spam before and it assigns it a spam
label this is known as classification
this is also used by researchers
especially in the legal industry lawyers
oftentimes receive hundreds of thousands
of documents if not millions of
documents they don't necessarily have
the human time to go through and analyze
every single document verbatim it is
important to kind of get a quick
umbrella sense of the documents without
actually having to go through and read
them page by page and so what lawyers
will oftentimes do is use nlp to do
classification and information
extraction they will find keywords that
are relevant to their case or they will
find documents that are classified
according to the relevant fields of
their case and that way they can take a
million documents and reduce it down to
maybe only a handful maybe a thousand
that they have to read verbatim
this is a real world application of nlp
or natural language processing and both
of these tasks can be achieved through
the spacey framework spacey is a
framework for doing nlp right now as of
2021 it's only available i believe in
python i think there is a community
that's working on an application with r
but i don't know that for certain but
spacey is one of many nlp frameworks
that python has available if you're
interested in looking at all of them you
can explore things like nltk the natural
language toolkit stanza which i believe
is coming out of the same program at
stanford
there's many out there but i find spacey
to be the best of all of them for a
couple different reasons reason one is
that they provide for you off the shelf
models that benchmark very well meaning
they perform very quickly and they also
have very good accuracy metrics such as
precision recall and f score i'm not
going to talk too much about the way we
measure machine learning accuracy right
now but know that they are quite good
second spacey has the ability to
leverage current natural language
processing methods specifically
transformer models also known
usually kind of collectively as bert
models even though that's not entirely
accurate
but it allows for you to use an
off-the-shelf transformer model and
third it provides the framework for
doing custom training relatively easily
compared to these other nlp frameworks
that are out there
finally the fourth reason why i pick
spacey over other nlp frameworks is
because it scales well spacey was
designed by explosion ai and the entire
purpose of spacey is to work at scale by
at scale we mean working with large
quantities of documents efficiently
effectively and accurately spacey scales
well because it can process hundreds of
thousands of documents with relative
ease in a relative short period of time
especially if you stick with more
rules-based pipes which we're going to
talk about in part two of this video
so those are the two things you really
need to know about nlp
and spacey in general we're going to
talk about spacey in depth as we explore
it both through this video and in the
free textbook i provide to go along with
this video which is located at
spacey.pythonhumanities.com
and it should be linked in the
description down below
this video and the textbook i meant to
work in tandem some stuff that i cover
in the video might not necessarily be in
the textbook because it doesn't lend
itself well to text representation and
the same goes for the opposite some
stuff that i don't have the time to
cover verbatim in this video i cover in
a little bit more depth in the video
in the in the book i think that you
should try to use both of these what i
would recommend is doing one pass
through this whole video watch it in its
entirety and get an umbrella sense of
everything that spacey can do and
everything that we're going to cover
i would then go back and try to
replicate each stage of this process
on a separate window or on a separate
screen and try to kind of follow along
in code and then i would go back through
a third time and try to watch the first
part where i talk about what we're going
to be doing and try to do it on your own
without looking at the textbook or the
video if you can do that by your third
pass you'll be in very good shape to
start using spacey to solve your own
domain specific problems
nlp is a complex field and applying nlp
is really complex but fortunately
frameworks like spacey make this project
and this process a lot easier i
encourage you to spend a few hours in
this video get to know spacey and i
think you're going to find that you can
do things that you didn't think possible
in relative short order
so sit back relax and enjoy this video
series on spacey in order to use spacey
you're first gonna have to install
spacey now there's a few different ways
to do this depending on your environment
and your operating system i recommend
going to spacey.io backslash usage and
kind of enter in the
correct framework that you're working
with so if you're using mac os versus
windows versus linux you can go through
and in this very handy
kind of user interface you can go
through and select the different
features that matter most to you i'm
working with windows i'm going to be
using pip in this case and i'm going to
be doing everything on the cpu and i'm
going to be working with english so i've
established all of those different
parameters and it goes through and it
tells me exactly how to go through and
install it using pip and the terminal so
i encourage you to go through pause the
video right now go ahead and install
windows however you want to i'm going to
be walking through how to install it
within the jupiter notebook that we're
going to be moving to in just a second
i want you to not work with the gpu at
all working with spacey on the gpu
requires a lot more understanding about
what the gpu is used for specifically in
training machine learning models it
requires you to have cuda installed
correctly it requires a couple other
things that i don't really have the time
to get into in this video but we'll be
addressing in a more advanced spacey
tutorial video
so for right now i recommend selecting
your os selecting either can use pip or
conda and then selecting cpu and since
you're going to be working through this
video with english texts i encourage you
to select english right now and go ahead
and just install or download the encore
web sm model this is the small model
i'll talk about that in just a second so
the first thing we're going to do in our
jupiter notebook is we are going to be
uh using the
the exclamation mark to delineate in the
cell that this is a terminal command
we're going to say pip
install spacey your output when you
execute this cell is going to look a
little different than mine i already
have spacey installed in this
environment and so mine kind of goes
through and looks like this yours will
actually go through and instead of
saying requirement already satisfied
it'll be actually passing out the the
different things that it's actually
installing to install spacey and all of
its dependencies
the next thing that you're going to do
is you're going to again you follow the
instructions and you're going to be
doing python dash m space spacey space
download and then the model that you
want to download so let's go ahead and
do that right now so let's go ahead and
say python
m
spacey
download so this is a spacey terminal
command and we're going to download the
n core web sm and again i already have
this model downloaded so on my end
spacey is going to look a little
differently than as it's going to look
on your end as it prints off on the
jupiter notebook
and if we give it just a second
everything will go through and it says
that it's collected it's downloading it
and we are all very happy now
and so now that we've got spacey
installed correctly and that we've got
the small model
downloaded correctly we can go ahead and
start actually using spacey and make
sure everything's correct the first
thing we're going to do is we're going
to import the spacey library as you
would with any other python library if
you're not familiar with this a library
is simply a set of classes and functions
that you can import into a a python
script so that you don't have to write a
whole bunch of extra code libraries are
massive collections of classes and
functions that you can call
so when we import spacey we're importing
the whole library of spacey and now that
we've see something like this we know
that spacey has imported correctly as
long as you're not getting an error
message everything wasn't was imported
fine the next thing that we need to do
is we want to make sure that our english
core web sm our small english model was
downloaded correctly so the next thing
that we need to do is we need to create
an nlp object i'm going to be talking a
lot more about this as we move forward
right now this is just troubleshooting
to make sure that we've installed spacey
correctly and we've downloaded our model
correctly so we're going to use the
spacey dot load command this is going to
take one argument it's going to be a
string that is going to correspond to
the model that you've installed in this
case n core web sm
and if you execute this cell and you
have no errors you have successfully
installed spacey correctly and you've
downloaded the english core web sm model
correctly so go ahead take time
and get all this stuff set up pause the
video if you need to and then pop back
and we're going to start actually
working through the basics of spacey
i'm now going to move into kind of an
overview of kind of what's within spacey
why it's useful and kind of some of the
basic features of it that you need to be
familiar with and i'm going to be
working from the jupiter notebook that i
talked about in the introduction to this
video if we scroll down to the bottom of
chapter one the basics of spacey and you
get past the install section you get to
this section on containers so what are
containers well containers within spacey
are objects that contain a large
quantity of data about a text
there are several different containers
that you can work with in spacey there's
the doc the doc bin example language
lexeme span span group and token we're
going to be dealing with the lexeme a
little bit in this video series and
we're going to be dealing with the
language container a little bit in this
video series but really the three big
things that we're going to be talking
about again and again is the doc the
span
and the token and i think when you first
come to spacey there's a little bit of a
learning curve about what these things
are what they do how they are structured
hierarchically and for that reason i've
created this in my opinion kind of easy
to understand
image of what different containers are
so if you think about what spacey is as
a pyramid so a hierarchical system we've
got all these different containers
structured around really the doc object
your doc container or your doc object
contains a whole bunch of metadata about
the text that you pass to the spacey
pipeline which we're going to see in
practice in just a few minutes
the doc object contains a bunch of
different things it contains attributes
these attributes can be things like
like sentences so if you iterate over
doc.sense you can actually access all
the different sentences found within
that doc object
if you iterate over each individual item
or index in your doc object you can get
individual tokens tokens are going to be
things like words or punctuation marks
something within your sentence or text
that has a
self-contained important value either
syntactically or semantically so this is
going to be things like words a comma a
period a semicolon a quotation mark
things like this these are all going to
be your tokens and we're going to see
how tokens are a little different than
just splitting words up with traditional
string methods in python
the next thing that you should be kind
of familiar with are spans so spans are
important because they kind of exist
within and without of the doc object so
unlike the token which is an index of
the doc object a span can be a token
itself but it can also be a sequence of
multiple tokens we're going to see that
at play so imagine if you
had a
a span in its category maybe group one
are um are places so a single token
might be like a city like berlin but
span group two this could be something
like full proper names so of of people
for example so this could be like as
we're going to see martin luther king
this would be a sequence of tokens a
sequence of three different items in the
sentence that make up one span or one
self-contained item so martin luther
king
would be
a person who's a collection of a
sequence of individual tokens if that
doesn't make sense right now this image
will be reinforced as we go through and
learn more about spacey and practice
for right now i want you to be just
understanding that the doc object is the
thing around which all of spacey sits
this is going to be the object that you
create this is going to be the object
that contains all the metadata that you
need to access and this is going to be
the object that you try to
essentially
improve with different custom components
factories and pipelines as you go
through and do more advanced things with
spacey we're going to now see in just a
few seconds how that doc object is kind
of similar to the text itself
but how it's very very different and
much more powerful
we're now going to be moving on to
chapter 2 of this textbook which is
going to deal with kind of getting used
to the in-depth features of spacey if
you want to pause the video or keep this
notebook or this book open up kind of
separate from this video and follow
along as we go through and explore it in
live coding we're going to be talking
about a few different things as we
explore chapter two this will be a lot
longer than chapter one we're going to
be not only importing spacey but
actually going through and loading up a
model
creating a doc object around that model
so that we're gonna work with the doc
container and practice and then we're
going to see how that dot container
stores a lot of different features or
metadata or attributes about the text
and while they look the same on the
surface they're actually quite different
so let's go ahead and work within our
same jupiter notebook where we've
imported spacey and we have already
created the nlp object
the first thing that i want to do is i
want to open up a text to start working
with within this repo
we've got a data folder within this data
subfolder i've got a couple different
wikipedia openings i've got one on mlk
that we're going to be using a little
later in this video then i have one on
the united states this is wiki
underscore us that's going to be what we
work with right now so let's use our
with operator
and open up data backslash wiki
underscore us.txt
we're going to just read that in as f
and then we're going to create this text
object which is going to be equal to f
dot read
and now that we've got our text object
created let's go ahead and see what this
looks like so let's print text
and we see that it's a standard
wikipedia article kind of follows that
same introductory format and it's about
four or five paragraphs long with a lot
of the features left in such as the
brackets that delineate some kind of a
footnote we're not going to worry too
much about cleaning this up right now
because we're interested not with
cleaning our data so much as just
starting to work with the doc object in
spacey
so the first thing that you want to do
is you're going to want to create a doc
object
it is oftentimes good practice if you're
only ever working with one doc object in
your script to just call your only
object doc if you're working with
multiple objects sometimes you'll say
doc1.2.3
or give it some kind of specific name so
that your variables can be unique and
easily identifiable later in your script
since we're just working with one doc
object right now we're going to say doc
is equal to
nlp so this is going to call
our nlp model that we imported earlier
in this case the english core web sm
model
and that's going to for right now just
take one argument and that's going to be
the text itself so the text object
if you execute that cell you should have
a doc object now created let's print off
that doc object and see what it looks
like
and if you scroll down you might be
thinking to yourself this looks
very very similar if not identical to
what i just saw a second ago
and in fact on the surface it is very
similar to that text object that we gave
to the nlp model or pipeline but let's
see how they're different let's print
off the length of text
and let's print off the length
of the doc object
and what we have here are two different
numbers our text is 3525
and our doc object is 652
what is going on here well let's get a
sense by trying to iterate over the text
object and iterating over the doc object
with a simple for loop so we're going to
say for token and text
so we can iterate first over that text
object we're going to print off the
token
so the first 10 indices and we get
individual letters as one might expect
but when we do something the same thing
with the doc object let's go ahead and
start writing this out we're going to
say for token and doc and we're going to
iterate over the first 10.
we're going to print off the token
we see something very different what we
see here are tokens this is why the doc
object is so much more valuable and this
is why the doc object has a different
length than the text object the text
object is just
basically counting up every instance of
a character a white space a punctuation
etc the doc object is counting
individual tokens so
any word any punctuation etc that's why
they're of different length and that's
why when we print them off we see
something different so you might now
already be seeing the power of spacey it
allows for you to easily on the surface
with nothing else being done easily
split up your text into individual
tokens without any effort at all now
those of you familiar with python and
different string methods
might be thinking to yourself but you
know i've got the split method i can i
can just use this to split up the text i
don't need anything fancy from spacey
well you'd be wrong let me demonstrate
this right now so if i were to say for
token and text dot split so i'm
splitting up that text into
individual in theory individual words
essentially it's just a split method
where it's splitting by individual white
spaces if i were to do that and iterate
over the first 10 again
and i would just say print token
it looks good until you get down here so
until you get to usa well why is it a
problem
the problem is quite simple there is a
parenthesis mark right here and this is
where we have a
a huge advantage with spacey
spacey automatically separates out these
these kind of punctuation marks and
removes them from individual tokens when
they're not relevant to the token itself
notice that usa has got a period within
the middle of it
it's not looking at that and thinking
that that is some kind of unique token a
u a period an s a period and an a and a
period it's not seeing these as four
individual tokens rather it's
automatically identifying them as one
thing one tied together single token
that's a string of characters and
punctuation
this is where the power of spacey really
lies just on the surface level and go
ahead spend a few minutes and play
around with this and then we're going to
kind of jump back here and start talking
about how the doc object has a lot more
than just tokens within it it's got
sentences each token has attributes
we're going to start exploring these
when you pop back
if you're following along with the
textbook we're now going to be moving on
to the next section which is sentence
boundary detection in nlp sentence
boundary detection is the identification
of sentences within a text on the
surface this might look simple you might
be thinking to yourself i could simply
use the split function and split up a
text with a simple period and that's
going to give me all my sentences those
of you who have tried to do this might
already be shaking your heads and saying
no if you think about it there's a
really easy explanation for why this
doesn't work were you to try to split up
a text by period and make a presumption
that anything that occurs with between
periods is going to be an individual
sentence you would have a serious
mistake when you get to things like usa
especially in western languages where
the punctuation of a period mark is used
not only to delineate the change of a
sentence rather it's used to also
delineate abbreviations so united states
of america each period represents an
abbreviated word so you could write in
rules to to kind of account for this you
could write in rules that could also
include in other ways that sentences are
created such as question marks such as
exclamation marks but why do that that's
a lot of effort
when the doc object in spacey does this
for you and let's go ahead and
demonstrate exactly how that works so
let's go ahead and say for
send and doc dot sense notice that we're
saying doc dot sends so we're grabbing
the sentence attribute of the doc object
let's print off send
and if you do that you are now able to
print off every individual sentence so
the entire text has been tokenized at
the sentence level in other words spacey
has used its sentence boundary detection
and done all that for you and given you
all the sentences
if you work with different models of
different sizes you're going to notice
that certain models the larger they get
tend to do better at sentence detection
and that's because machine learning
models tend to do a little bit better
than heuristic approaches the english
core web sm model while having some
machine learning components in it
does not save word vectors and so the
larger you go with the models typically
the better you're going to have with
regards to sentence detection
let's go ahead and try to access one of
these sentences so let's create an
object called sentence one we're going
to make that equal to dot doc dot sense
zero so we're going to try to grab that
zero index and let's print off sentence
one
if we do this we get an error why have
we gotten an error well it tells you why
right here it's a type error and this
means that this is not a type that can
be kind of iterated over it's not
subscriptable and it's because it is a
generator now in python if you're
familiar with generators you might be
thinking to yourself there's a solution
for this and in fact there is
if you want to work with generator
objects you need to convert them into a
list so let's say sentence one is equal
to list
so using the list function to convert
doc dot sense into a list and then with
outside of that we're gonna grab
zero the zero index and then we're gonna
print off sentence one
and we grab the first sentence of that
text this
as we go deeper and deeper and spacey
one by one you're going to see the
immense power that you can do with paseo
all the immense incredible things you
can use spacey for with very very
minimal code the doc object does a lot
of things for you that would take hours
to actually write out in code to do with
heuristic approaches this is now a great
way to segment an entire text up by
sentence and if you work with text a lot
you'll already know that this has a lot
of applications
as we move forward we're going to not
just talk about sentences we're also
going to be talking about token
attributes because within the doc object
are individual tokens i encourage you to
pause here and go ahead and play around
with the doc.sense a little bit and get
familiar with how it works what it
contains and try to convert it into a
list once you've done that pop back here
and we'll continue talking about tokens
this is where i really encourage you to
spend a little bit of time with the
textbook under token attributes in
chapter 2 i have all the different kind
of major things that you're going to be
using with regards to token attributes
we're going to look and see how to
access them in just a second i've
provided for you kind of the most
important ones that you should probably
be familiar with we're going to see this
in code in just a second and i'm going
to explain with a little bit more detail
than what's in this spacey documentation
about what these different things are
why they're useful and how they're used
so let's go ahead and jump back into our
jupiter notebook and start talking about
token attributes
if you remember the doc object had a
sequence of tokens so for token and doc
you could print off token and let's just
do this with the first 10
and we've got each individual token
what you don't see here is that each
individual token has a bunch of metadata
buried within it these metadata are
things that we call attributes or
different
things about that token that you can
access
through
the spacey framework so let's go ahead
and try to do that right now let's just
work with for right now token number two
which we're gonna call sentence
one and we're gonna grab from sentence
one the second index let's print off
that word
and it should be states and in fact it
is fantastic
so now that we've got the word states
accessed we can start kind of going
through and playing around with some of
the attributes that that word actually
has now when you print it off it looks
like a regular piece of text looks like
just a string but it's got so much more
buried within it now because it's been
passed through our nlp
model our pipeline from spacey so let's
go ahead and say token2.text
and i'm going to be saying token2.txt if
you're working within an ide like adam
you're going to need to say print
token2.txt
when we do this we see we get a string
that just is states this is telling us
that the dot text of the object the pure
text corresponds to the word states this
is really important if you need to
extract the text itself from the token
and not work with the token object which
has behind it a whole bunch of different
metadata that we're going to go through
now and start accessing
let's use the the token left edge so we
can say token2 dot
left underscore edge and we can print
that off well what's that telling us
it's telling us that this is part of a
multi-word token or a token that is
multiple has multiple components to make
up a larger span
and that this
is the leftmost token that corresponds
to it so this is going to be the word
the as in the united states let's take a
look at
the right edge we can say token2 dot
right underscore edge print that off and
we get the word america so we're able to
see where this token fits within a
larger span in this case a noun chunk
which we're going to explore in just a
few minutes but we also learn a lot
about it
kind of the different components so we
know where to grab it from the beginning
and from the very end so that's how the
left edge and the right edge work
we also have within this token
2 dot and type
this is going to be the type of entity
now what you're seeing here is a integer
so this is 384 in order to actually know
what 384 means i encourage you to not
really use that so much as and type with
an underscore after it this is going to
give you the string corresponding to
number 384 in this case it is gpe or
geopolitical entity we're going to be
working with named entity a little bit
in this video but i have a whole other
book on named entity recognition it's at
ner.pythonhumanities.com
in which i explore all of any r both
machine learning and rules-based in a
lot more depth let's go ahead and keep
on moving on though and looking at
different entity types here as well so
are not entity types attribute types so
we're going to say token2 dot
int
i o b all lowercase and again an
underscore at the end and we get the
the string here i now iob is a specif a
specific kind of named entity code a b
would mean that it's the beginning of an
entity and i means that it's inside of
an entity and o means that it's outside
of an entity
the the fact that we're seeing i here
tells us that
this word states is inside of a larger
entity and in fact we know that because
we've seen the left edge and we've seen
the right edge it's inside of the united
states of america so it's part of a
larger entity at hand
we can also say token2
dot lima
and under case again after that and we
get the word states this is the limit
form or the root form of the word this
means that this is what the word looks
like with no inflection if we were
working with a verb in fact let's go
ahead and do that right now let's grab
sentence
uh we're going to grab sentence 1
index 12 which should be the word no
and we're going to print off the lemma
for the word sorry it's
a verb
and we see the verb lemma as no so if we
were to print off sentence one
specifically
index 12 we see that its original form
is known so the lima form uninflected is
the verb no k k-n-o-w
another thing that we can access and
we're going to see that have the power
of this later on this might not seem
important right now but i promise you it
will be
let's print off
token what did i call this again token
token2
we're going to print that off but we're
going to print off specifically the
morph
no underscore here just morph what you
get is what looks like a really weird
output a
string called noun type equal to prop in
fact this means proper noun
a number which corresponds to sing we're
going to talk a lot more about
morphological analysis later on when we
try to find and extract information from
our texts but for right now understand
that what you're looking at is the
output of kind of what that word is
morphologically so in this case it's a
proper noun and it's singular if we were
to do
take this
sentence 12 again and do morph
we'd find out what kind of verb it is so
it's a perfect
past
participle
known perfect past participle remember
being good at nlp is also being good
with language so i encourage you to
spend time and start getting familiar
with those things that you might have
forgotten about from like fifth grade
grammar such as perfect participles and
things like that because when you need
to start creating rules to extract
information you're going to find those
pieces of information very important for
writing rules
we'll talk about that in a little bit
though let's go back to our other
attributes from the token so again let's
go to token2 and we're going to grab the
part of speech not what you might be
thinking so part of speech underscore
pos underscore and we output p-r-o-p-n
this means that it is a proper noun it's
more of a of a simpler kind of
grammatical
extraction as opposed to this
morphological detailed extraction what
kind of noun it might be with regards to
in this case singular so that's going to
be how you extract the part of speech
another thing that you can do is you can
extract the
dependency relation so in this case we
can figure out
what role it plays in the sentence in
this case the noun subject
and then finally the last thing i really
want to talk about before we move into a
more detailed analysis of part of speech
is going to be the token 2
dot
lang and what this grabs for you is the
language of the doc object in this case
we're working with something from the
english language so en every language is
going to have two letters that
correspond to it these are universally
recognized so that's going to be how you
access different kinds of attributes
that each token has and there's about 20
more of these or maybe not 20 maybe
about 15 more of these that i haven't
covered i gave you the ones that are the
most important that i find to be used on
a regular basis to solve different
problems with regards to information
extraction from the text
so that's going to be where we stop here
with
token attributes and we're going to be
moving on to part 2.5 of the book which
is part of speech tagging
i now want to move into kind of a more
detailed analysis of part of speech
within spacey and the dependency sparser
parser and how to actually analyze it
really nicely either in a notebook or
outside of a notebook so let's work with
a different text for just a few minutes
we're going to see why this is important
it's because i'm working on a zoomed in
screen and to make this sentence a
little easier to understand we're going
to just use
mike and joy's plane
football a very simple sentence and
we're going to create a new doc object
and we're going to call this doc 2
that's going to be equal to nlp
text let's print off doc 2 just to make
sure that it was created and in fact we
see that it was now that we've got it
created let's iterate over the tokens
within this and say for token
in text we want to print off
token
dot text we want to see what the text
actually is we want to see the token
dot pos
and the token dot dep
oh it helps if you actually iterate over
the correct object over the doc2 object
and we see that we've got mic
proper noun noun subject and joy's verb
it's the root
uh plain in this case it's a verb
and then we've got football the noun the
direct object and a period which is the
punctuation so we can see the basic uh
semantics of the sentence at play what's
really nice from spacey is we have a way
to really visualize this information and
how these words relate to one another so
we can say from spacey import displacy
and we're going to do displacy
display c dot render
and this is going to take two arguments
it's going to be the text
and then it's going to be
the
actually it's going to be doc2 and then
it's going to be style in this case
we're going to be working with dep
and we're going to print that off and we
actually see how that
sentence is structured now in the
textbook i use a more complicated
sentence but for the reasons of this
video i've kept it a little shorter just
because i think it displays better on
the screen because you can see that this
becomes a little bit more difficult to
understand when you're zoomed in but
this is one sentence from that wikipedia
article
so go ahead and look at the textbook and
see how elaborate this is you can see
how it's part of a compound how it's
preposition
you can see the the more fine-tuned
grain fine-grained aspects of the
dependency parser and the part of speech
tagger really at play with more
complicated sentences so that's going to
be how you really access part of speech
and how you can start to visualize how
words in a sentence are connected to
other words in this sentence with
regards to their part of speech and
their dependencies
that's going to be where we stop with
that in the next section we're going to
be talking about named entity
recognition and how to visualize that
information
so named entity recognition is a very
common nlp task it's part of kind of
data extraction or information
extraction from texts it's oftentimes
just called ner named entity recognition
i have a whole book on how to do any r
with python and with spacey but we're
not going to be talking about all the
ins and outs right now we're just going
to be talking about how to access the
the pieces of information throughout
kind of our our text and then we're
going to be dealing with a lot of ner as
we try to create elaborate systems to do
named entity extraction for things like
financial analysis
so let's go ahead and figure out how to
iterate over a doc object so we're going
to say for int and
doc.n so we're going to go back to that
original doc the one that's got the
the first
kind of the text from wikipedia on the
united states
we're going to say print off
and dot text so the the text from it and
end dot label label underscore here
that's going to tell us what label
corresponds to that text
and we print this off we've got a lot of
gpes which are geopolitical entities on
north america this isn't a geopolitical
entity it's just a general location 50 a
cardinal number five cardinal number
norp indian in this case which is a
national or religious
political entity
quantity the number of miles canada gpe
as you would expect paleo indians norp
once again siberia lock
and we have date being extracted so at
least 12 000 years ago this is a small
model and it's extracting for us a lot
of very important structured data but we
can see that the small model
makes mistakes so the revolutionary wars
being considered an organization
were i to use a large model right now
which i can download separately from
spacey we're going to be seeing this
later in this video or where i'd use the
much larger transformer model this would
be correctly identified most likely as
an event not as an organization but
because this is a small model that
doesn't contain word vectors which we're
going to talk about in just a little bit
it does not generalize or make
predictions well on this particular data
nevertheless we do see really good
extraction here we have the american
civil war being extracted as an event we
have the spanish-american war even with
this encoding typographical era here
and world war being extracted as an
event world war ii event cold war event
all of this is looking good uh and not
really i only saw a couple basic
mistakes but for the most part this is
what you'd expect to see we even see
percentages extracted correctly here
so this is how you access really vital
information about your tokens but more
importantly about the entities found
within your text and also displacy
offers a really nice way to visualize
this in a jupiter notebook we can say
displacey.render
we can say doc
style
we can say end
and we get this really nice
visualization where each entity has its
own particular color so you can see
where these entities appear within the
text as you kind of just naturally read
it you can do this with the text as long
as you want you can even change the max
length to be more than a million
characters long
and again we can see right here org is
incorrectly identified as the american
revolutionary war and correctly
identified as org but nevertheless we
see really really good results with a
small english model without a lot of
custom fine-tuned training and there's a
reason for this a lot of wikipedia data
gets included into machine learning
models so machine learning models on
text typically make good predictions on
wikipedia data because it was included
in their training process nevertheless
these are still good results if i'm
right or wrong on that i'm not entirely
certain
but that's going to be how you kind of
extract important entities from your
text and most importantly visualize it
this is where chapter 2 of my book kind
of ends after this chapter you have a
good understanding hopefully of kind of
what the dot container is what tokens
are and how the doc object contains the
attributes such as synths and ends which
allows you to find sentences and
entities within a text
hopefully you also have a good
understanding of how to access the
linguistic features of each token
through token attributes i encourage you
to spend a lot of time becoming familiar
with these
basics as these basics are the building
block for really robust things that
we're going to be getting into
in the next few lessons
we're now moving into chapter 3 of our
textbook on spacey and python
now in chapter three we're going to be
continuing our theme of part one where
we're trying to understand the larger
building blocks of spacey
even though this video is not going to
deal with spacing machine learning
approaches are custom ones that is it's
still important to be familiar with what
machine learning is and how it works
specifically with regards to language
because a lot of the spacey models such
as the medium
large and transformer models all are
machine learning models that have word
vectors stored within them this means
that they're going to be larger more
accurate and do
things a bit bit more slowly uh
depending upon its size
so we're going to be working through not
only
what kind of machine learning is
generally but specifically how to how it
works with regards to
texts and i think that this is where
you're going to find this textbook to be
somewhat helpful
so what i want to do is in our new
jupyter notebook we're going to import
spacey just as we did before but this
time we're going to be installing a new
model so we're going to do python m
the
exclamation mark python m spacey
download
and then we're going to download the n
core
md model
so this is the medium english model this
is going to take a little longer to
download and the reason why i'm having
you download the media model and the
reason why we're going to be using the
media model is because the medium model
has stored within it
word vectors well that's downloading
let's go ahead and talk a little bit
about what word vectors are
and how they're useful so word vectors
are word embeddings so these are
numerical representations
of words in multi-dimensional space
through matrices
that's a very compacted sentence so
let's break it down what are word
vectors used for well they're used for a
computer system to understand
what a word actually means so computers
can't really parse text all that
efficiently they can't parse it at all
every word needs to be converted into
some kind of a number now for some old
approaches you would use something like
a bag of words approach where each
individual word would have a
corresponding number to it this would be
a unique number that corresponds just to
that word
for
a lot of tasks that that can work but
for something like text understanding or
trying to get a computer system to be
able to understand
how how a word functions within a
sentence in general so in other words
how it works in the in the language how
it relates to all other words that
doesn't really work for us
so what a word vector is is it's a
multi-dimensional representation so
instead of a a number having just a
single integer that corresponds to it it
instead has what looks like to uh
to
an unsuspecting eye essentially it has a
very complex sequence of floating
numbers that are stored as an array
which is a computationally less
expensive
form of a list in python or just
computing in general and this is what it
looks like a long sequence in this case
i believe it's a 300 dimensional word
that corresponds to a a specific word
so this is what an array or a word
vector or a word embedding looks like
what this means to a computer system is
it means syntactical and semantical
meaning so the way word vectors are
typically trained is oh there's a few
different approaches but kind of the old
school word to vec approach is you give
a computer system a whole bunch of texts
and different smaller larger collections
of texts and what it does is it reads
through all of them and figures out how
words are used
in relation to other words and so what
it's able to essentially do through this
training process is figure out meaning
and what that meaning allows for a
computer system to do is understand how
a word might relate to other words
within a sentence or within a language
as a whole in order to understand this i
think it's best if we move away from
this textbook and actually try to
explore what word vectors look like in
spacey so you can have a better sense of
specifically what they do why they're
useful and how you as a nlp practitioner
can go ahead and start leveraging them
so just like before we're going to
create an nlp object this time however
instead of loading in our encore web sm
we're going to load in our n core web m
d so the one that actually has these
word vectors store these static vectors
saved and it's going to be a larger
model let's go ahead and execute that
cell and while that's executing we're
going to start opening up our text so
we're going to say with open data wiki
underscore us.txt
r as
f
we're going to say text is equal to f
dot read so we're going to successfully
load in that text file and open it up
then we're going to create our doc
object which will be equal to nlp
text all the syntax is staying the exact
same and just like before let's grab the
first sentence
so we're going to convert our doc
dot sense generator into a list and
we're going to grab
index zero and let's go ahead and print
off sentence one just so you can kind of
see it and there it is
so now that we've got that kind of
in memory we can start kind of
working with it a little bit so let's go
ahead and just start tackling how we can
actually
use word vectors with spacey
so let's kind of think about
a general question right now let's say i
wanted to know
how the word let's say country
is similar to
other words within
our models word embeddings so let's
create a little way we can do this we're
going to say your word and this is going
to be equal to the word country
country
there we go and what we can do is we can
say ms is equal to
nlp so we're going to go into the nlp
object
we're going to grab the vocab
dot vectors and we're going to say most
similar
and this is a little complicated way of
doing it in fact i'm going to go ahead
and just kind of copy and paste this in
you have the code already in your
in your textbook that you can follow
along with and i'm going to go ahead and
just copy and paste it in
right here
and print off this
what this is going to do is it is going
to go ahead and just do this
entirely there we go
and we have to import numpy as mp
this lets us actually work with the data
as a numpy array and when we execute
this cell what we get
is an output that tells us all the words
that are most similar to the word
country so in this scenario the word
country it has
these kind of all these different
similar words to it from the word
country
to the word country capitalized nation
nation now it's important to understand
what you're seeing here what you're
seeing is not necessarily a synonym for
the word country rather what you're
seeing is are the words that are the
most similar now this can be anything
from a synonym to a variant spelling of
that word
to something that occurs frequently
alongside of it so for example world
while this isn't the same
we would never consider world to be the
synonym of country
but what happens is is syntactically
they're used in very similar situations
so the way you describe a country is
sometimes the way you would describe
your world or maybe it's something to do
with the hierarchy so a country is found
within the world
this is a good way to understand it so
it's always good to use this word as
most
similar
not
to be something like
synonym so when you're talking about
word vector similarity you're not
talking about synonym similarity keep
that in mind but this is a way you can
kind of quickly get a sense so what does
this do for you why did i go through and
explain all these things about word
vectors if i'm not going to be talking
about machine learning a whole bunch
throughout this video well i did it so
that you can do one thing that's really
important and that's calculate document
similarity and spacey so we've already
got our nlp model loaded up let's create
one object so we're going to make doc1
we're going to make that equal to nlp
and we're going to create the text right
here in this object so let's say
this is coming straight from the spacey
documentation i like salty fries and
hamburgers
and we're gonna say doc 2 is equal to
nlp and this is going to be the text
fast
food tastes
very good
and now we can do is let's go ahead and
load those into memory what we can do is
we can actually make a calculation using
spacey to find out how similar they
actually are these two different
sentences so we can say print off doc1
and we're gonna say
this again this is coming straight from
the spacey documentation
doc2 so you're going to be able to see
what both documents are and then we're
going to do doc 1 dot similarity so we
can go into the doc 1 dot similarity
method and we can compare it to doc two
we can print that off
so what we're seeing here on the left is
document one
this little divider thing that we
printed off here
on the right we have document two and
then we can see the degree of similarity
between document one and document two
let's create another doc object we're
gonna call this nlp
doc3 and we're gonna make this nlp let's
come up with a sentence uh this is
completely different the empire
state building
is in
new york so this is one i'm just making
up off the top of my head right now i'm
going to copy and paste this down and
we're going to compare this
to doc one we're going to compare it to
doc three and we get a score of 0.51 so
this is
less similar
to than these two so this is a way that
you can take a whole bunch of documents
you can create a simple for loop and you
can find and start clustering the
documents that have a lot of overlap or
similarity how is this similarity being
calculated well it's being calculated
because what spacey is doing is it's
going into its word embeddings
and even though in these two situations
we're not using the word fast food ever
in this document it's going in and it
knows that salty fries and hamburgers
are probably in a close cluster with the
bigram or a token that's made up of two
words a bigram of fast food so what it's
doing is it's assigning a prediction
that these two are still somewhat
similar more similar than these two
because of these overlapping in words so
let's try one more example see if we can
get something that's really really close
so let's take doc 4 and this is going to
be equal to nlp
i enjoy
oranges
and then we're going to have doc 5 is
going to be equal to nlp
i enjoy apples so 2 i would agree i
would argue very very syntactically
similar sentences and we're going to do
doc 4 here
doc 5 here and we're going to look and
see a similarity between doc 4
and doc 5. if we execute this we get
a similarity of 0.96 so this is really
high this is telling me that these two
sentences are very similar and it's not
just that they're similar because of
the the similar syntax here that's
definitely pushing the number up it's
that what the individual is liking in
the scenario between these two texts
they're both fruits let's try something
different let's make doc five
let's just make doc 6 here
and do something like this nlp
i
enjoy what's another word we could say
something that's different
let's say burgers something different
from a fruit so we're gonna make doc six
like that and we're gonna again copy and
paste this down
copy and paste this down we're gonna put
dot
six here
and we see this drop so what this
demonstrates i'm really glad this worked
because i improvised this uh what this
demonstrates is that the similarity
the number that's given is not dependent
on
the contextual words
rather it's dependent upon the semantic
similarity
of the words so apples and oranges are
in a similar cluster
around fruit
because of their word embeddings the
word burgers while still being food and
still being plural is
different from apples and oranges so in
other words this similarity is being
calculated based on something that we
humans would calculate difference in
meaning based on a a large understanding
of a language as a whole that's where
word vectors really come into play this
allows for you to calculate other things
as well so you could even calculate the
difference between salty fries and
hamburgers for example i've got this
example ready to go in the textbook
let's go ahead and try this as well so
we're going to grab doc 1
and
and print off these few things right
here so we're gonna try to calculate the
similarity between french fries and
burgers and what we get is a similarity
of 0.73
so
if we were to maybe change this up a
little bit
and try to calculate the similarity
between maybe just the word uh
burgers rather than hamburgers and
burgers and hamburgers we would have a
much higher similarity so my point is is
play around with the similarity
calculator play around with this
structure the code i provided here and
get familiar with how
spacey can help you kind of find
similarity not just between documents
but between words as well
and we're going to be seeing how this is
useful later on but again it's good to
be familiar with kind of generally how
machine learning kind of functions here
in this context and why these medium and
large models are so much bigger they're
so much bigger because they have more
word vectors that are much deeper and
the transformer model is much larger
because it was trained in a completely
different method than the way the medium
and large models were trained but again
that's out of the scope for this video
i now want to turn to the really the
last subject of this introduction uh to
spacey part one which is when we're
taking this large umbrella view of
spacey and in the textbook it's going to
correspond to chapter four so what we go
over in this textbook is kind of a large
view of the not just the doc container
and the word vectors and the linguistic
annotations but really kind of the
structure
of the spacey framework which comes
around the the pipeline so a pipeline
is a very common expression in computer
science and in data science think of it
as a traditional pipeline that you would
see in a house now think of a pipeline
being a sequence of different pipes
each pipe in a computer system is going
to perform
some kind of permutation or some action
on
a piece of data as it goes through the
pipeline and as each pipe has a chance
to act and make changes to in addition
to that data
the later pipes get to benefit from
those changes so this is very common
when you're thinking about logic of code
i provided like a little image here that
i think maybe might help you so if we
imagine
some input sentence right so some input
text is entering a spacey pipeline it's
going to go through a bunch of things if
you're working with the media model or
the small model that'll tokenize it and
give it a word and vector
for different words it'll uh it'll also
you know find the the pos the part of
speech the dependency part so we'll act
on it but it might eventually get to
a an entity ruler which we're going to
see in just a few minutes uh the entity
ruler will be a series of rules based
ner named entity recognition so it'll
maybe assign uh an a token to an entity
might be the beginning of a of an entity
might be the end of an entity might just
be an individual token entity and then
uh what will happen is is that doc
object as it kind of goes through this
pipeline will now receive a bunch of doc
dot ins so it'll be uh this pipe will
actually add
to the um to the dock object as it goes
through the pipeline the entity
component and then the next pipeline the
entity linker might take all those
entities and try to find out which ones
they are so
it'll oftentimes be connected to some
kind of wiki data some kind of
standardized number that corresponds to
a specific person so for example if you
were seeing a bunch of things like paul
something paul something
maybe that one paul something might be
paul hollywood from the great british
bake off and it might have to make a
connection to a specific person so if
it's a the word paul being used
generally this entity linker would
assign it to paul hollywood depending on
the context that's out of the scope of
this video series but keep in mind that
that
pipe would do something else that would
modify the ins that would give them
greater specificity and then what you'd
be left with is the dot object on the
output that not only has entities
annotated but it's also got entities
linked to some generic specific data so
that's going to be how a pipeline works
and this is really what spacey is it's
it's a sequence of pipes that act on
your data and that's important to
understand because it means that as you
add things to a spacey pipeline you need
to be very conscientious about where
they're outed and in what order as we're
going to see as we move over to kind of
rules based spacey when we start talking
about these different types the entity
ruler the matcher custom components
regex components you're going to need to
know which order to put them in it's
going to be very important
so do please keep that in mind now
spacey has a bunch of different
attribute rulers or different pipes you
can kind of add into it you've got
dependency parsers that are going to
come standard with all of your models
you've got the entity linker and d
recognizer entity ruler you're going to
have to make these yourself and add them
in oftentimes you've got a limit tizer
this is going to be on most of your
standard models your morpholog that's
going to be on on there as well sentence
recognizer sentenceizer this is what
allow for you to have the doc.sense
right here span categorizer this will
help categorize different span
spans be them single token spans or
sequence of token spans your tagger this
will tag the different things in your
text
which will help with part of speech your
text categorizer this is when you train
a machine learning model to recognize
different categories of a text so text
classification which is a a very
important machine learning task toke to
vec this is going to be what assigns
word embeddings to the different words
in your doc object
tokenizer is what breaks that thing up
and all all your text into individual
tokens and you got things like
transformer and trainable pipes
then within this you've also got some
other things called matchers so you can
do some dependency matching we're not
going to get into that in this video
you've also got the ability to use
matcher and phrase matcher these are a
lot of the times can do some similar
things but they're executed a little
differently to make things less
confusing i'm really only talking about
the matcher of these two and if there's
a need for it i'll add into the textbook
the phrase matcher at a later date but
i'm not going to cover it in this video
and if i do add in the phrase matcher
it's going to be after this mattress
section here i have it in the github
repo i just haven't included in the
textbook to keep things a little bit
simpler at least if you're just starting
out so
a big good question is well how do you
add pipes to a spacey pipeline so let's
go ahead and do that we're going to make
a blank spacey pipeline right now let's
go ahead and just make
we'll just work with the same
live coding notebook that we have open
right now so what we're going to do is
we're going to make a blank model and
we're going to actually add in our own
sentenceizer to
our
to our text so let's go ahead and do
that
so i'm going to say nlp is equal to
spacey.blank this is going to allow for
me to make a blank
spacing a pipeline and i'm going to say
en so that it knows that the tokenizer
that i need to use is the english
tokenizer
and now if i want to add a pipe to that
i can use one of the built-in spacey
features so i can say add underscore
pipe
and i can say sentenceizer so i can add
in a sentenceizer this is going to allow
for me to create a pipeline now
that has a sequence of two different
pipes and i demonstrate in the textbook
why this is important sometimes what you
need to do is you need to just only
break down a text into individual
sentences so i grabbed a massive
massive corpus from the internet
which is on
mit.edu and it's the entire shakespeare
corpus and i just try to calculate the
the quantity of sentences found within
it there are 94 133 sentences and it
took me only 7.54 seconds to actually go
through and count those sentences with
the spacey model using the small model
however it took a total amount of time
of 47 minutes to actually break down all
those sentences and extract them why is
there a difference in time between 7
seconds and 47 minutes it's because that
this spacey small model has a bunch of
other pipes in it that are trying to do
a bunch of other things if you just need
to do one task it's always a good idea
to
just activate one pipe
or
maybe make a blank model and just add
that single pipe or the only pipes that
you need to it a great example of this
is needing to tokenize a whole bunch of
sentences in relatively short time so i
don't know about you but i'd be much
happier with seven seconds versus 47
minutes
that however comes at a trade-off the
small model is going to be more accurate
in how it finds sentence boundaries and
so we have a difference in quantity here
this difference in quantity indicates
that this one messed up and made some
mistakes because it was just the
sentenceizer the sentenceizer didn't
have extra data being fed to it in fact
if i probably used larger models i might
even have better results but always
think about that if time is of the
essence and you don't care so much about
accuracy a great way to get the quantity
of sentences or at least a ballpark is
to use this method where you simply add
in a sentenceizer to a blank model so
that's how you actually add in
different
different pipes to a spacey pipeline and
we're going to be reinforcing that skill
as we go through especially in part two
where we really kind of work with this
in a lot of detail right now i'm just
interested in giving you the general
understanding of
how this might work so let's go ahead
and try to analyze
our pipeline so we can do analyze
underscore pipes and we can analyze what
our analyze there we go we can actually
analyze our pipeline if we look at the
nlp object which is our blink model with
the synthesizer we see that our nlp
pipeline or sorry our nlp pipeline
ignore summary ignore this bit here
but what you're actually able to kind of
go through and see right away
is that we've really just got the
sentence sizer sitting in it if we were
to analyze a much more robust pipeline
so let's create nlp2 as equal to spacey
dot load and core web sm we're going to
create that nlp2 object around the small
space email english model
we can analyze the pipes again and we
see a much more elaborate pipeline so
what are we looking at well what we're
looking at is a sequence of things we've
got uh in the pipeline a tagger after
the toketovec we've got a tagger a
parser
we keep on going down we've got an
attribute ruler we've got a limitizer
we've got the ner that's what designs
the doc dot ends
and we keep on going down we can see the
limit tizer
but we can see also a whole bunch of
other things we can see what these
different things actually assign so
um doc dot ends assigns the ner and
require and we can also see what each
pipe might actually require so if we
look up here we see that the ner pipe
so the named recognition pipe is
responsible for assigning the doc dot
ends so that attribute of the the doc
object and it's also responsible at the
token level for assigning the end.iob
underscore iob which is the if you
remember from a few minutes ago when we
talked about
the iob being the uh opening beginning
or out beginning inside for
a different entity uh it also assigns
the int dot and underscore type for each
token attribute so you can see a lot of
different things about your pipeline by
using nlp
dot analyze underscore pipes
if you've gotten to this point in the
video then i think you should by now
have a good really umbrella view of what
spacey is how it works why it's useful
and some of the basic features that it
can do and how it can solve some pretty
complex problems with some pretty simple
lines of code what we're going to see
now moving forward is how you as a
practitioner of nlp cannot just take
what's given to you with spacey but
start working with it and start
leveraging it for your own uses so
taking what is already available so like
these models like the english model and
adding to them contributing to them
maybe you want to make uh an entity
ruler where you can find more entities
in a text based on some kazetty or list
that you have
maybe you want to make a matcher so you
can find specific sequences within a
text maybe that's important for
information extraction
maybe you need to add custom functions
or components into a spacey pipeline i'm
going to be going through in part two
rules based spacey and giving you all
the basics of how to do some really
robust custom things
relatively quickly with a within the
spacey framework all that's going to lay
the groundwork so that in part three we
can start applying all these skills and
still start solving some real world
problems in this case we're going to
look at financial analysis so that's
going to be where we move to next is
part two
we are now moving into part two of this
jupiter book on spacey and we're going
to be working with rules based spacey
now this is really kind of the bread and
butter of this video you've gotten a
sense of the umbrella structure of
spacey as a framework you've gotten a
sense of what the doc container can
contain you've gotten a sense of the the
token attributes and the linguistic
annotations from part one of this book
in the earlier part of this video now
we're going to move into taking those
skills and really developing them into
custom components and
modified pipes that exist within spacey
in other words i'm going to show you how
to take what we've learned now and start
really doing more robust and
sophisticated things with that knowledge
so we're going to be working first with
the entity ruler then with the matcher
in the next chapter then in the
components in spacey so a custom
component is a custom function that you
can put into a pipeline then we're going
to talk about regex or regular
expressions and then we're going to talk
about some advanced rejects with spacey
if you don't know what regex is i'm
going to cover this in
chapter 8. so let's go over to our
jupiter notebook that we're going to be
using for our entity ruler lesson so
let's go ahead and execute some of these
cells and then i'm going to be talking
about it in just a second
first i want to take some time to
explain what the entity ruler is
as a pipe and spacey what it's used for
why you'd find it useful and when to
actually implement it so there are two
different ways in which you can kind of
add in custom features to a spacey
language pipeline there is a rules-based
approach and a machine learning-based
approach rules-based approaches should
be used when you can think about how to
generate a set of rules based on either
a list of known things or a set of rules
that can be generated through regex
code or linguistic features machine
learning is when you don't know how to
comp like to actually write out the
rules or the rules that you would need
to write out would be exceptionally
complicated a great example of a
rules-based approach versus a machine
learning based approach and when to use
them is with
entity types for named entity
recognition imagine if you wanted to
extract dates from
a from a text there are a finite very
finite number of ways that a date can
appear in a text you could have
something like january 1 2005 you could
have one january 2005 you could have one
jan 2005 you could have one slash
five slash 2005 there's there's
different ways that you can do this and
there's a lot of them but there really
is a finite number that you could easily
write a regex expression for a regular
expression for to capture all of those
and in fact those regex expressions
already exist that's why spacey is
already really good at identifying dates
so
dates are something that you would
probably use a rules-based approach for
something that's a good machine learning
approach for are something like names if
you wanted to capture the names of
people
you would have to generate an entity
ruler with a whole bunch of robust
features so you would have to have a
list of all known possible first names
all known possible last names all known
possible prefixes like doctor mr mrs
miss miss it's master etc and you'd have
to have a list of all known suffixes so
junior senior the third the fourth
etcetera on the list
this would be very very difficult to
write because
first of all the quantity of names that
exist in the world are massive the
quantity of last names that exist in the
world is massive there's not a set
gazetteer or a set list out there of
these anywhere so for this reason
oftentimes things like people names will
be worked into machine learning
components i'm going to address machine
learning in another video at a later
date for right now we're going to focus
on a rules-based approach so using the
the rules-based features that spacey
offers
a good nlp practitioner will be
excellent at both rules-based approaches
and machine learning-based approaches
and knowing when to use which approach
and when
maybe
maybe a task is not appropriate for
machine learning when it can be worked
in with rules relatively well if you're
taking a rules-based approach the
approach that you take should have a
high degree of confidence that the rules
will always return true positives and
you need to think about that if you are
okay with your rules maybe catching a
few false positives or missing a few
true positives
then maybe think about how you write the
rules and allowing for those and making
it known in your documentation so that's
generally what a rules-based approach is
and an entity ruler is a way that we can
use a list or a series of features
language features to add tokens into the
entity the dot ins container within the
doc container so let's go ahead and try
to do this right now
the text we're going to be working with
is a kind of fun one i think so if
you've already gotten the reference
congratulations it's kind of obscure
but we're going to have a sentence right
here that i just wrote out west
chesterton fieldville was referenced in
mr deeds so in this context we are going
to have a few different entities we want
our model or our pipeline to extract
west chesterton fieldville as a gpe it's
a fake place that doesn't really exist
it was made up in the movie mr deeds and
what we want is for mr deeds to be
grabbed as an entity as well and this
would ideally be labeled as a film but
in this case that's probably not going
to happen let's go ahead and see what
does happen so we're going to say for
end and doc dot ends
print off and dot text
and dot label like we learned from our
nar lesson a few a few moments ago and
we see that the output looks like this
it's gotten almost all the entities that
we wanted mister was left off of deeds
and it's grabbed the west chesterton
fieldville and labeled it as a person so
what's gone wrong here well there's a
few different things that have gone
wrong the encore web sm model is a
machine learning model for ner the word
vectors are not saved so the static
vectors are not in it so it's making the
best prediction that it can but even
with a very robust machine learning
model unless it has seen west chesterton
fieldville there is not really a good
way
for
the model to actually know that that's a
place
unless it's seen
a structure like west chesterton
and maybe it can make up a guess a
transformer model might actually get
this right but for the most part this is
a very challenging thing this would be
challenging for a human there's not a
lot of context here to tell you what
this kind of entity is unless you knew a
lot about how
maybe northeastern villages and
towns
in the
north america would be called
also mr deeds is not extracted as a
whole entity just deeds's now ideally
we would have an ner model that would
label west chesterton fieldville as a
gpe and mr deeds as a film but we've got
two problems one the machine learning
model doesn't have film as an entity
type and on top of that westchester
tinfieldville is not coming out correct
as gpe so our goal right now is to fix
both of these problems with an entity
ruler this would be useful if i were
maybe doing some text analysis on
fictional places referenced in films so
things like narnia maybe middle earth
west chesterton fieldville these would
all be classified as kind of fictional
places so let's go ahead and make a
ruler to correct this problem so what
we're going to do is first we're going
to
make a ruler by saying ruler is equal to
nlp
dot
add pipe
and this is going to take one argument
here
you're going to find out when we start
working with custom components that you
can have a few different arguments here
especially if you create your own custom
components but for right now we're
working with the components that come
standard with spacey there's about 18 of
them one of them is the entity
underscore
ruler all lower case we're going to add
that ruler into our nlp model and if we
do nlp.analyze
underscore pipes
and execute that we can now look at our
ner model and see as we go down that the
uh the ner pipe is here
and the entity ruler is now the exit the
final pipe in our pipeline so we see
that it has been successfully added
let's go ahead now and try to add
patterns into that pipeline
patterns are the things that
the spacey model is going to look for
and the label that it's going to assign
when it finds something that meets that
pattern
this will always be a list of lists so
let's go ahead and do this right now
sorry a list of dictionaries so
the first pattern that we're really
looking for here is going to be
a dictionary it's going to have one
key of label which is going to be equal
to gpe
and another label of pattern
which is going to be equal to in this
case we want to find west chesterton
fieldville let me go ahead and just copy
and paste it so i don't make a mistake
here
and what we want to do is we want our
entity ruler to see west chesterton
fieldville and when it sees it assign
the label of gpe so it's a geopolitical
entity so it's a place
so let's go ahead and execute that great
we've got the patterns now comes time to
load them into the ruler so we can say
ruler dot add underscore patterns
this is going to take one argument
it's going to be our list of patterns
it in
cool now let's create a new doc object
we're going to call this doc2 that's
going to be equal to nlp
we're going to pass in that same text
we're going to say for ent and doc2.ens
print off and dot text and end dot label
you're going to notice
that nothing has changed
so why has nothing changed we're still
getting the same results and we've added
the correct pattern in
the answer lies into one key thing if we
look back up here
we see that our entity ruler comes after
our nar what does that mean well imagine
how the pipeline works that i talked
about a little while ago in this video a
pipeline works by different components
adding things to an object and making
changes to it in this case adding ends
to it
and then
making those things isolated from later
pipes from being able to overwrite them
unless specified what this means is that
when west chesterton field bill goes
through
and is identified by the ner pipe as a
person it can no longer be identified as
anything else
what this means is that you need to do
one of two things give your ruler the
ability to overwrite the nur or this is
my personal preference
put it before the ner in the pipeline so
let's go through and solve this common
problem right now
we're going to create a new nlp object
called nlp2
which is going to be equal to
spacey.load and again we're going to
load in the english core web sms model
encore web sm
great and again we're going to do ruler
dot
nlp2 dot add pipe
entity
ruler and we're going to make that
an object too
now what we can do is we can say
ruler.add patterns
again we're going to go through all of
these steps that we just went through
we're going to add in those patterns
that we created up above
and now what we're going to do is we're
going to actually do one thing a little
different than what we did
what we're going to do is we're going to
load this up again and we're going to do
an extra keyword argument now we can say
either after or before here
we're going to say before any r
what this is going to do is it's going
to place our ner before our entity ruler
before the ner component
and now when we add our patterns in
we can now create a new doc object
doc it's going to be equal to nlp2
text and we're going to save for int and
doc dot ins
print off int dot text and dot label
and now we notice that it is correctly
labeled as a gpe why is this well let's
take a look at our nlp 2 object
i'm going to analyze pipes
and if we scroll down
we will notice that our entity ruler now
in the pipeline sits before the ner
model in other words we've given primacy
to our custom entity ruler so that it's
going to have the first shot at actually
correctly identifying these things but
we've got another problem here
deeds is coming out as a person it
should be mr deeds as the
as the entire
as the entire collective multi-word
token and that should be a new entity we
can use the entity ruler to add in
custom types of labels here so let's go
ahead and do this same thing
let's uh let's go ahead and just copy
and paste our patterns
and we're going to create one more
nlp object we're going to call this nlp3
is equal to spacey.load
in core
web sm
great we've got that loaded up we're
going to do the same thing we did last
time nlp three or sorry ruler
is equal to nlp.add underscore pipe
entity
ruler we're going to place it remember
going to place it before the ner pipe
oh nlp three there we go
and what we need to do now is we need to
copy in these patterns and we're gonna
add in one more pattern remember this
can be a list here
so this pattern we're gonna have
a new label called film
and we're going to look for the sequence
mr
deeds
and that's going to be our pattern that
we want to add in to our ruler so we can
do ruler.add underscore patterns
we're going to add in patterns remember
that one keyword argument or one
argument is going to be the list itself
and now we can create a new doc object
which is going to be equal to nlp 3 i
think i called it yep
text
and we can say for int and doc dot ents
print off end.text and end
dot label and if we execute this we see
now that not only have you gotten the
entity ruler to correctly identify west
chesterton fieldville we've also gotten
the entity ruler to identify correctly
mr deeds as a film now some of you might
be realizing the problem here this is
actually a problem for machine learning
models and the reason for this is
because mr deeds in some instances could
be the person and mr deeds in other
instances could be the movie itself this
is what we would call a toponym it's a
spell like this this is a common problem
in natural language processing and it's
actually one of the few problems or one
of many problems really they remain a
little bit unsolved toponym resolution
it's about like this or tr
is the resolution of toponym so things
that can have multiple labels that are
dependent upon context another example
of toponym resolution is something like
this if you were to look at this word
and let's say let's ignore paris hilton
let's ignore paris from greek mythology
let's say it's only going to ever be a
gpe the word paris could refer to paris
france paris kentucky or paris texas
potopian resolution is also the ability
to resolve problems like this when in
context is paris
kind of
talking about paris france when in
context is it talking about kentucky and
when in context is it talking about
texas so
that's something that you really want to
think about with when you're generating
your rules for an entity ruler is
is this ever going to be a false
positive
and if the answer is that it's going to
be a false positive half the time or
um it's a 50 50 shot then then really
consider incorporating that kind of an
entity into a machine learning model by
giving it examples of both mr deeds in
this case as a film and mr deeds as a
person so we can learn with word
embeddings
when that context means it's a film and
when that context means it's a person
that's just a little toy example what
we're going to see moving forward though
and we're going to do this with the
matcher not with the entity ruler is
that
spacey can do a lot of things you might
be thinking to yourself now i could
easily just come up with a list and just
check and see whenever mr deeds pops up
and just inject that into the doc.ins i
could do the same thing with wes
chesterton field build why do i need an
nlp framework to do this and the answer
is going to come up in just a few
minutes when we start realizing that
spacey can do a lot more than things
like regex or
things like just a basic gazetteer check
or a list to check
what you can do with spacey is you can
have the pattern not just take a
sequence of characters and look for a
match but a sequence of linguistic
features as well that earlier pipes have
identified and i think it's best if we
save that for just a second when we
start talking about the matcher which is
in my opinion one of the
more robust things that you can do with
spacey and what sets spacey apart from
things like regex or fancy or other
fancy or string matching approaches
okay we're now moving into chapter six
of this book and this is really kind of
my opinion one of the most important
areas in this entire video if you can
master the techniques i'm going to show
you for the next maybe 20 minutes or so
maybe 30 minutes
you're going to be able to do a lot with
spacey and you're really going to see
really kind of its true power a lot of
the stuff that we talk about here in the
matcher can also be implemented in the
entity ruler as well with a pattern
the the key difference between the
entity ruler and the matcher is in how
data the data is kind of extracted so
the matcher is going to store
information
a little differently it's going to store
it as within the vocab of the nlp model
it's going to store it as a unique
identifier or a lexiem spelt lex eme i'm
going to talk about that more in just a
second
and it's not going to store it in the
doc ends so matchers don't put things in
your
in your doc dot ends so when do you want
to use a match over an entity ruler uh
you want to use the entity ruler when
the thing that you're trying to extract
is something that is important to have a
label that corresponds to it within the
entities that are coming out
so
i in my research i use this for anything
from like let's say stocks if i'm
working with finances i'll use this for
if i'm working with holocaust data at
the u.s hmm where i am a postdoc i'll
try to add in
camps and ghettos because those are all
important annotated
alongside other entities i'll also work
in things like ships so the names of
ships streets things like that
when i use the the matcher it's when i'm
looking for something that is
not necessarily an entity type but
something that is a
structure within the text that'll help
me extract information and i think
that'll make more sense as we go through
and i show you kind of how to improve
examples uh going through it we're kind
of using the matcher as you would in the
real world but remember all the patterns
that i show you can also be implemented
in the entity ruler and i'm also going
to talk about when we get to chapter
eight how regex can actually be used to
do similar things but in a different way
essentially when you want to use the
matcher or the entity ruler over regex
is when linguistic components so the
lemma of a word or the
identifying if the the word is a
specific type of an entity that's when
you're going to want to use the matcher
over regex and when you want to use
regex is when
you really have a complicated pattern
that you need to extract
and that pattern is not dependent upon
specific parts of speech you're going
gonna see with that how that works as we
kind of go through the rest of part two
but keep that in the back of your mind
so let's go ahead and take our work over
to our blank jupiter notebook again so
what we're gonna do is we're gonna just
set up with a basic example we need to
import spacey and since we're working
with the matcher we also need to say
from spacey dot matcher import matcher
with a capital m very important capital
m
once we have this loaded up we can start
actually working with the matcher and
we're going to be putting the matcher
in a
a just a small
english model
and we're going to say nlp is equal to
spacey.load and you should be getting
familiar with this encore web sm
the small english model
once we've got that loaded and we do now
we can start actually working with the
matcher so how do you create the matcher
well the pythonic way to do this and the
way it's in the documentation is to call
the object a matcher that's going to be
equal to matcher with a capital m
so we're calling this class right here
and now what we need to do is we need to
pass in one argument
this is going to be nlp.vocab
going to see that we can add in some
extra features here in just a little bit
i'm going to show you why you'd want to
add an extra features at this stage but
we're going to ignore that for right now
what we're going to try to do is we're
going to try to find email addresses
within a text a very simple task that's
really
not that difficult to do we can do it
with a very simple pattern because
spacey has given us that ability so
let's create a pattern
and that's going to be equal to a list
which is going to be equal to or that's
which is going to contain a dictionary
the first item in the dictionary
or the first key
is going to be
the
the thing that you're looking for so in
this case we have a bunch of different
things that the matcher can look for and
i'm going to be talking about all those
in just a second but one of them is very
handily this this label of like email so
if the if the string or the sequence of
tokens or the token is looking like an
email
and that's true
then that is what we want to extract we
want to extract everything that looks
like an email and to make sure that this
occurs we're going to say matcher dot
add and then here we're going to pass in
two arguments argument one is going to
be the think of it as a label that we
want to assign to it
and this is what's going to be added
into the nlp.vocab as a lex scene which
we'll see in just a second and the next
thing is a pattern
and it's important here to note that
this is a list
the
argument here takes a list of lists and
because this is just one list right now
i'm making it into a list so each one of
these different patterns would be
a list within a list essentially
the let's go ahead and execute that and
now we're going to say doc is equal to
nlp
and i'm going to add in a text that i
have in the textbook
and this is my email address w mattingly
aol.com uh that might be a real email
address i don't believe it is it's
definitely not mine so don't try and
email it
and then we're gonna say matches is
equal to matcher
doc and this is gonna be how we find our
matches we pass that doc object
into our matcher class
and now what we have is the ability to
print off our matches and what we get is
a list
and this list is a set of tuples that
will always have three indices
so index zero
is going to be this very long number
what this is is this is a lexeme spelled
like this ali x eme it's in the textbook
and the next thing is the start token
and the end token so you might be seeing
the importance here already what we can
do with this is we can actually go into
the nlp vocab
where this integer lies and find what it
corresponds to so this is where this is
pretty cool check this out
so you print off
nlp.vocab so we're going into that vocab
object
we're going to index it it matches
zero so this is going to be the the
first index so this tuple at this point
and then we're going to grab index 0. so
now we've gone into this list we've gone
to index 0 this first tuple and now
we're grabbing that first item there now
what we need to do is we need to say dot
text oop
need to do it right here
if we print this off we get this email
address that label that we gave it up
there was added into the nlp vocab with
this unique lex seam that allows for us
to understand what that number
corresponds to within the nlp
framework
so
this is a very simple example of how a
mattre works and how you can use it to
do some pretty cool things
but let's take a moment let's pause and
let's see what we can do with this
matcher so if we go up into spacey's
documentation on the matcher we'll see
that you've got a couple different
attributes you can work with now we've
uh we're going to be seeing this a
little bit the orth this is the exact
verbatim of a token
and
we're also going to see text the exact
verbatim
text of a token what we also have is
lower
so what you can do here is you can use
lower to say when the item is lower case
and it looks like and then give some
lower case
pattern this is going to be very useful
for capturing things that might be at
the start of a sentence
for example if you were to look for
the penguin in the text anywhere you saw
the penguin
if you used a pattern that was just
lowercase you wouldn't catch the penguin
being at the start of a sentence it
would miss it because the t would be
capitalized by using lower you can
ensure that your pattern that you're
giving it is going to be looking for any
pattern that matches that when the text
is lowercased
length is going to be the uh the length
of your token text
is alpha is ascii is digit this is when
your characters are either going to be
alphabetical ascii characters so uh the
american standard coding initiative i
can't remember what it stands for but
it's that i think it's 128-bit thing
that america came up with when they
started encoding text
uh it's now replaced with utf-8 and is
digit is going to look for something if
it is a digit so think of each of these
as a token so if the token is a digit
then that counts in the pattern
is lower is upper is title these should
be all self-explanatory if it's lower
case if it's uppercase if it's a title
so capitalized and if you don't
understand what all these do right now
i'm going to be going through and
showing you in just a second just giving
you an overview of different things that
can be included within the uh the
matcher or the entity ruler here
so what we can also do is find something
that uh if the token is actually the
start of a sentence
if it's like a number like a url like an
email you can extract it and here is the
main part i want to talk about because
this is where you're really going to
find spacey outshines any other string
matching system out there so what you
can do is you can use the tokens part of
speech tag morphological analysis
dependency label lima and shape to
actually make matches so not just
matching a sequence of characters but
matching a sequence of linguistic
features so think about this if you
wanted to capture all instances of a
proper noun followed by a verb you would
not be able to do that with regex
there's not a way to do it you can't
give regex if this is a verb regex is
just a string matching framework it's
not a framework for actually identifying
linguistic features using them and
extracting them so this is where we can
leverage all the power of spaces earlier
pipes the tagger the morphological
analysis the
the debt dilemma etc so the lemmatizer
we can actually use all those things
that have been have gone through the
pipeline and the master can leverage
those linguistic features and make some
really cool uh allow us to make really
cool patterns that can match really
robust and complicated things
and the final thing i'm going to talk
about is right here the op this is the
operator or quantifier it determines how
often to match a token so there's a few
different things you can use here
there's the exclamation mark negate the
pattern requiring it to max zero times
so in this scenario the sequence would
never occur there's the question mark
make the pattern optional allowing it to
match zero or
one times
require the pattern to match one or more
times with the plus and the asterisk the
thing on the shift eight allow the
pattern to match zero or more times
there's other things as well that you
can do to make this matcher a bit more
robust but for right now let's jump into
the basics and see how we can really
kind of take these and apply them in a
real world question
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
work with
another data set or another piece of
data that i've grabbed off of wikipedia
and this is the the wikipedia article
entry on martin luther king jr it's the
opening opening few paragraphs let's
print it off and just take a quick look
and this is what it looks like you can
go through and read it we're not too
concerned about what it says right now
we're concerned about trying to extract
a very specific set of patterns what
we're interested in grabbing are all
proper nouns that's the task ahead of us
somebody has asked us to take this text
in
extract all the proper nouns for me but
we're going to do a lot more and not
just the proper nouns but we want to get
multi-word tokens so we want to have
martin luther king jr extracted as one
token so one export so the other things
that we want to have are these kind of
structured in
sequential order so
find out where they appear and extract
them based on their start token so let's
go ahead and start trying to do some of
these things right now let's scroll down
here
great so we've we need to create really
a new nlp object now at this point so
let's create a new one we're gonna again
we're just gonna start working with the
n core web sm model if you're working
with a different model like the large or
the the transformer you're gonna have
more accurate results but for right now
we're just trying to do this quickly for
demonstration purposes
so again just like before
we're creating that with nlp.vocab
and then we're going to create a pattern
so this is the pattern that we're going
to work with
we want to find any occurrence of a pos
part of speech
that corresponds to
proper noun that's the the
way in which pos labels proper nouns is
prop n
and we should be able to with that
extract all proper nouns so we can say
matcher dot add and we're gonna say
proper
noun
and that's gonna be our pattern
and then what we can do just like before
we're going to create the doc object
this is going to be nlp text
and then we're going to say matches is
equal to matcher
doc so we're going to create the matches
by passing that doc object
uh into our matcher class
and then we're gonna print off the
length of the matches so how many
matches were found and we're gonna say
for match in matches and we're just
gonna grab the first 10 because i've
done this and there's a lot and you'll
see why
let's print off
let's print off in this case match and
then we're going to print off
specifically what that text is remember
the output is the lexeme
followed by the start token and the end
token which means we can go into the doc
object
and we can set up something like this we
can say
match
one so index one which is the start
token and match 2 which is the end token
and that'll allow us to actually index
what these words are and when we do this
we can see all these printed out so this
is the match
the lexeme here which is going to be
proper noun all the way down
we've got the
zero here which corresponds to the start
token the end token and this is the the
token that we extracted martin luther
king jr michael king jr we've got a
problem here right so the problem should
be pretty obvious right now
the problem is that we
have grabbed
all proper nouns but
these proper nouns are just individual
tokens we haven't grabbed the multi-word
tokens so how do we go about doing that
well we can solve this problem by let's
go ahead and just copy and paste all
this from here
and we're going to make one small
adjustment here
we're going to change this
to op
with a plus
so what does that mean well let's pop
back into our matcher
under spacey and check it out
so op remember is the operator a
quantifier
we're going to use the plus symbol so
it's going to look for a proper noun
that occurs one or more times so in
theory right this should allow us to
grab multi-word tokens it's going to
look for a proper noun and grab as many
as there are so anything that occurs one
or more times if we run this though we
see a problem we've gotten martin we got
martin luther what we got luther what we
got martin luther king luther king king
martin luther king jr what is going on
here well you might already have figured
it out it has done exactly what we told
it to do
it's grabbed all
uh sequence of tokens that were proper
nouns that occurred one or more times it
just so happens some of these overlap so
token that's dock 0 to 1
0 to 2 so you can see the problem here
is it's grabbing all of these in any
combination of them
what we can do though is we can add an
extra layer to this so let's again copy
what we've just done because it was it
was almost there it was good but it
wasn't great we're going to do one new
thing here when we add in the patterns
we're going to pass in the keyword
argument greedy
we're going to say longest capital all
capital letters here and if we execute
that it's going to look for the longest
token out of that mix and it's going to
give that one
make that one the only token that it
extracts
we notice that our length has changed
from what was it up here 175
to 61.
so this is much better however we should
have recognized right now
another problem what have we done wrong
well what we've done wrong is these are
all out of order in fact what happens is
when you do this i i don't have evidence
to support this but i believe it's right
what will always happen is the the
greedy longest will result in all of
your tokens being organized are all your
matches being organized from longest to
shortest so if we were to scroll down
the list and look at maybe negative one
uh negative let's do negative 10 on
you'll see single word tokens and again
this is me just guessing but i think
based on what you've just seen that's a
fairly good guess so let's go ahead and
just cut so we can see what the output
is here so how would you go about
organizing these sequentially
well this is where
really kind of a
sort comes in handy when you can pass
a lambda to it let's go back and copy
all this again because again we almost
had this right here we're going to sort
our matches though
we can say matches dot sort
this is going to take a keyword argument
of key which is going to be equal to
lambda and lambda is going to allow us
to actually iterate over all this and
find any instance where x
occurs and we're going to say to sort by
x1 so what this is it's a list of tuples
and what we're using lambda for is we're
going to say sort this whole list of
tuples out but sort it by the first
index in other words sort it by the
start token when we execute that we've
got everything now coming out as we
would expect and nor these typos that
exist
we've got zero to four
six to nine so we actually are
extracting these things in sequential
order as they appear in our text so
that's how you can actually go through
and sort the appearance of the
of the matcher but what if our uh the
person who kind of gave us this job they
were happy with this
but they came back and said okay that's
cool but what we're really interested in
what we really want to know
is every instance where a proper noun of
any length
uh grab the multi-word token still but
we want to know anytime that occurs
after a verb so anytime this proper noun
is followed by a verb so what we can do
is we can add in okay okay we can do
this we're going to have a comma here so
the same pattern is going to be a
sequence now it's not just going to be
uh one thing we're going to say token
one
needs to be a proper noun and grab as
many of those tokens as you can zero or
not one two more times and then after
those are done comma this is where the
next thing has to occur
pos so the part of speech needs to be a
verb so the next thing that comes out
needs to be a verb and we want that to
be the case
when we do this we can kind of go
through and see the results so the first
instance of this
where a proper noun is proceeded by a
verb comes in token 50 to 52 king
advanced uh 258 director j edgar hoover
considered now we're able to use those
linguistic features that make spacey
amazing and actually extract some vital
information so we've been able to figure
out
where in this text a
a proper noun is proceeded by a verb so
you can already start to probably see
the implications here and we can ex we
can create very elaborate things with
this we can use any of these as long of
a sequence as you can imagine we're
going to work with a different text and
kind of demonstrate that it's a fun toy
example i've got a
halfway cleaned copy of alice in
wonderland stored as a json file
i'm going to load it in right now
and then i'm going to just grab
the first sentence from the first
chapter
and what we have here is the first
sentence
so here's our scenario somebody has
asked us to grab
all the quotation marks and try to
identify
the person described
or the person described the person who's
doing the speaking or the thinking in
other words we want to be able to grab
alice thought now i picked alice in
wonderland because
of the complexity of the text not
complexity in the sense of the language
used children's book but complexity and
the syntax the syntax is highly
inconsistent yes and not cs lewis um
carol lewis c carroll was highly
inconsistent in how he structured these
kind of sequences of quotes and the
other thing i chose to do as i left in
one mistake here and that is this
non-standardized quotation mark so
remember when you need to do this things
need to patch perfectly so we're going
to replace this first things first is to
create a cleaner text where we do text
equals text dot replace
and we're going to replace the instance
of i believe it's that mark but let's
just copy and paste it in to make sure
we're going to replace that with a
with a single quotation mark
now we can print off text just to make
sure that that was done correctly cool
great it was it's now looking good
remember whenever you're doing
information extraction standardize the
texts as much as possible things like
quotation marks will always throw off
your data
now that we've got that
let's go ahead and start trying to
create
a fairly robust pattern to try to grab
all instances where there is a quotation
mark
thought
something like this
and then
followed by another quotation mark so
the first thing i'm going to try and do
is i'm going to try to just capture all
quotation marks in a text so let's go
through and try to figure out how to do
that right now so we're going to copy in
a lot of the same things that we used up
above
but we're going to make some
modifications to it let's go ahead and
copy and paste all that we're going to
completely change our pattern
so let's get rid of this so what are we
looking for well first of all the first
thing that's going to occur in this
pattern is this
quotation mark so that's going to be a
full text match which is an orth if you
remember
and we're going to have to use double
quotation marks to add in that single
quotation mark so that's what we grab
first we're going to look for anything
that is an orth and the next thing
that's going to occur after that i think
this is good to probably do this now on
a line by line basis so we can keep this
straight
so the next thing that's going to occur
is we're looking for anything in between
so anything that is an alpha character
we're going to just grab it all so
is
alpha
and then we need to say true
but within this we need to specify how
many times it occurs because if we say
is true it's just going to look at the
next token
in this case and
and then say that's the end that's it
that's the pattern we got to extract it
but we want to grab not just and but and
what is the use of
everything
so we need to grab
uh not only that but we say op so our
operator again and if you said plus
you would be right here we need to make
sure that it's a plus sign so it's
grabbing everything now in this scenario
this is a common construct
is when you have a injection here in the
middle of the sentence so thought or
said and it's the character doing it
it's oftentimes got a a comma right here
so we need to add in that kind of a
feature so there could be
is punct
there could be a punk here
and we're going to say that that
is equal to true but that might not
always be the case there might not
always be one there so we're going to
say op
is equal to
a star we go back we'll see why if we go
back to our op
the star allowed the pattern to match
zero or more times so in this scenario
the punctuation
may or may not be there so that's the
next thing that occurs once we've got
that
the last thing that we need to match
is the exact same thing that we had at
the start
is this orth up here
and that's our sequence so this is going
to look for anything that starts with a
quotation mark has a series of alpha
characters
has a punctuation like a comma possibly
and then closes the quotation marks if
we execute this
we we succeeded we got it we extracted
both matches from that first sentence
there are no other quotation marks in
there but our task was not just to
extract this information our task was
also to
match who is the speaker now we can do
this in a few different ways and you're
going to see why this is such a
complicated problem in just a second so
let's go ahead and do this how can we
make this better
well we're going to have this occur
twice
but
in the middle we need to figure out when
somebody is speaking so
one of the things that we can do is we
can make a list so let's make a list of
limitized forms
of our verbs
so we're going to say
let's call this speak underscore limits
it's going to be equal to a list
and the first thing we're going to say
is think because we know that think is
in there and say this is the limitized
form of thought and said
so what we can do now is after that
occurs let's add in a new thing
we're going to be able to now add in a
new pattern that we're looking for it's
not just a start of a query quotation
mark not just the end of a quotation
mark
but also a sequence that'll be something
like this so it's going to be a part of
speech so it's going to be a verb that
occurs first right
and that's going to be a verb but more
importantly it's going to be a lemma
that is
in
what did i call these speak
lemmas so let's break this down
the next token
needs to be a verb
and it needs to have a limitized form
that
is contained within
the speak limas list so if it's got that
fantastic let's execute this and see
what happens we should only have one hit
cool we do so we've got that first hit
and the second one hasn't appeared
anymore because that second quotation
mark wasn't proceeded by a verb let's go
ahead and make some modifications that
we can improve this a little bit because
we want to know not just what what that
person's doing
we also need to know who the speaker is
so
let's grab it let's let's figure out who
that speaker is so we can use part of
speech
again another feature here we know that
it's going to be a proper noun because
oftentimes proper nouns are doing the
speaking sometimes it might not be
sometimes it might be like the girl or
the boy lower case but we're going to
ignore those situations for just right
now
so we're looking for a proper noun but
remember proper nouns as we saw just a
second ago
could be multiple tokens so we're going
to say op plus so it could be a sequence
of tokens let's execute this
now we've captured alice here as well so
and is the use and what is the use of a
book thought alice now we know who the
speaker is but this is a partial
quotation this is not the whole thing we
need to grab the other quote how how
will we ever do that well we've already
solved that we can copy and paste all of
this that we already have done
right down here
and now
we've successfully extracted
that entire quote so you might be
thinking to yourself yeah we did it we
can now extract quotation marks
and we can even extract um
extract you know
any instance where there's a quote and
somebody speaking
not so fast let's try to iterate over
this data so we're going to say for text
in data
0 2 so we're going to iterate over the
the first chapter
and we're going to
go ahead and let's do all of this
doc is going to be equal to that sort
that out
and then again we're going to be
printing out
this information the same stuff i did
before just now it's going to be
iterating over the whole chapter and if
we let this run we've got a serious
serious problem
and it doesn't actually grab us anything
nothing has been grabbed successfully
what is going on
we've got a problem
and that problem stems from the fact
that our patterns
and the problem is that we don't have
our our text correctly
being removing the uh that quotation
mark that was the the problem up above
so we're going to add this bit of code
in
and we're going to be able to fix it
so now when we execute this we see that
we've only grabbed one match now you
might be thinking to yourself there's an
issue here and there there is let's go
ahead and print off the length of
matches
and we see that we've only grabbed one
match
and then we haven't grabbed anything
else well what's the problem here are
there are there no other instances of
quotation marks in the rest of the first
chapter and the answer is no that there
are there absolutely are
other quotation marks and other
paragraphs from the first chapter the
problem is is that our pattern is
singular
it's not multi-varied we need to add in
additional ways in which a
a text might be structured
so let's go ahead and try and do this
with some more patterns i'm going to go
ahead and copy and paste these in
from the textbook so you'll be able to
actually see them at work
and so what i've did i've done is i've
added in more patterns pattern two and
pattern three allow for instances like
this
well thought alice so an instance where
there's a punctuation but there's no
proceeding quotation after this
and then which certainly said before an
instance where there's a comma
followed by that so we've been able to
capture more variants and more ways in
which quotation marks might exist
followed by the speaker
now this is where being a domain expert
comes into play you'd have to kind of
look through and see the different ways
that louis c carroll structures
quotation marks and write out patterns
for capturing them i'm not going to go
through and try to capture everything
from alice in wonderland because that
would take a good deal of time
and it's not really in the best interest
because it doesn't matter to me at all
what i encourage you to do if this is
something interesting to you is try to
apply it to your own texts different
authors structure quotation marks a
little differently the patterns that
i've gotten written here are a good
starting point but i would encourage you
to start playing around with them a
little bit more and what you can do is
when you actually have this match
extracted you know that the instance of
a proper noun that occurs between these
quotation marks or after one is probably
going to be the person or thing that is
doing the speaking
or the thinking so that's kind of how
the matcher works it allows you to do
these things these robust
type data extractions without relying on
entity ruler remember you can use a lot
of these same things with an entity
ruler as well but we don't want this in
this case we don't want things like this
to be labeled as entities we want them
to just be separate things that we can
extract outside of the of the ins dot
doc dot ends that's going to be where we
conclude our chapter on
on the on the matcher in the next
section of this video we're going to be
talking about custom components in
spacey which allow for us to do some
pretty cool things such as add in uh
special functions that allow for us to
kind of
do different custom shapes uh
permutations on our data with
components that don't exist like an
entity ruler would be a component
components that don't exist within the
spacey framework so add in custom things
like an entity ruler that do very
specific things to your data
hello we're now moving into a more
advanced aspect of the textbook
specifically chapter 7 and that's
working with custom components a good
way to think about a custom component is
something that you need to do to the doc
object or the doc container
that spacey can't do off the shelf you
want to modify it at some point in the
pipeline so i'm going to use a basic toy
example that demonstrates the power of
this let's look at this basic example
that i've already loaded into memory
it's uh two sentences that are in the
doc object now
and then britain is a place mary is a
doctor so let's do for end and doc dot
ins print off and dot text
and dot label
and we see what we'd expect britain is
gpe a geopolitical entity mary is a
person
that's fantastic but i've just been told
by somebody higher up that they want the
model to never ever give anything as gpe
or maybe they want any instance of gpe
to be flagged as loc
so all the different locations all have
loc as a label or we just want to remove
them entirely so i'm going to work with
that latter example we need to create a
custom pipe that removes all instances
of gpe from the doc.ins container so how
do we do that well we need to use a
custom component we can do this very
easily in spacey by saying from
spacey.language
import language capital l very important
there capital l
now that we've got that class loaded up
let's start working with this what we
need to do first is we need to use
a flag so the symbol and we need to say
at language dot component
and we need to give that component a
name we're gonna save in this case let's
say remove
gpe
and now we need to create a function to
do this so we're gonna call this remove
gpe i always kind of keep these as the
same that's my personal preference and
this is going to take one
one one thing that's going to be the doc
object so the doc object think about how
it moves through the pipeline this
component is another pipe and that
pipeline it needs to receive the dock
object and send off the dock object you
could do a lot of other things it could
print off entity found it could do
really any number of things it could add
stuff to
the data coming out of the pipeline
all we're concerned with right now is
modifying the doc.ns
so we can do something like this
we can say original
ends is equal to a list of the doc.ns so
now remember we have to convert the ins
from a generator into a list now what we
can do is we can save for int and
doc.ents
if the end not label so if that label is
equal to gpe
then what we want to do
is we want to just we just want to
remove it so let's say
original ins dot remove and we're going
to remove the end remember it's now a
list oop sorry i executed that too soon
remember it's now a list so what we can
do is we can
go ahead now and convert those original
ends back into doc dot ends by saying
doc dot ins equals original ins and if
we've done things correctly we can
return the doc object and it will have
all of those things removed so this is
what we would call a custom component
something that changes the doc object
along the way in the pipeline but we
need to add it to nlp so we can do nlp
dot add pipe
we want to make sure that it comes after
the ner so we're just going to say
add the pipe or move gpe
corresponds to the component name
and now let's go ahead and nlp.analyze
pipes
and you'll be able to see that it sits
at the end of our pipeline right there
remove gpe
now comes time to see if it actually
works so we're going to copy and paste
our code from earlier up here
let's go ahead and
copy this
and now we're going to say for end and
doc dot ends
print off end.text
and dot label and we should see as we'd
expect just mary coming out
our pipeline has successfully worked now
as we're going to see when we move into
regex you can do a lot of really really
cool things with custom components i'm
going to kind of save the the advanced
features for i think i've got it
scheduled for chapter here chapter 9 in
our textbook this is just a very very
basic example of how you can introduce a
custom component to your spacey pipeline
if you can do this you can do a lot more
you can maybe change a different entity
so they have different labels you can
make it where gpes and locks all agree
you can remove certain things you can
have it print off place found person
found you can do a lot
so really the sky's the limit here but a
lot of the times you're going to need to
modify that doc object and this is how
you do it with a custom pipe so that you
don't have to write a bunch of code for
a user
outside of that nlp object that nlp
object once you save it to disk by doing
something like nlp nlp.2
disk
data
new
n core web sm
it's going to actually be able to go to
the disk and be saved with everything
but one thing that you should note is
that the component that you have here is
not automatically saved with your data
so in order for your component to
actually be saved with your data you
need to store that outside of
this entire
script you need to save it as a library
that can be given to
the model when you go to package it
that's beyond the scope of this video
for right now in order for this to work
in a different jupiter notebook if you
were to try to use this
this container this component has to
actually
be in the script when it comes time to
package your model your pipeline and
distribute it that's a different
scenario in that scenario you're going
to make sure that you've got a special
my component.pi file with this bit of
code in there so that so that spacing
knows how to handle your particular data
it's now time to move on to chapter
eight of this textbook and this is where
spacey gets really interesting you can
start applying regular expressions into
a spacing component like an entity ruler
or a custom component as we're going to
see in just a moment with chapter 9.
am not going to spend a good deal of
time talking about regular expressions i
could spend five hours talking about
regex and what all it can do in the
textbook i go over what you really need
to know which is what regular
expressions is which is as a way to do a
really robust string pattern matching i
talk about the strengths of it the
weaknesses of it that's drawbacks how to
implement it in python and how to really
work with regex but this is a video
series on spacey what i want to talk
about is how to use regex with spacey
and so let's move over to a jupyter
notebook where we actually have this
code to execute and play around with
if we look here we have the same example
that we saw before what my goal is is
not to extract the whole phone number
rather try to grab this sequence here
and we do this with a regular expression
pattern what this says is it tells it to
look for a sequence of tokens or
sequence of characters like this it's
going to be three digits followed by a
dash followed by uh four digits and if i
were to execute this whole code nothing
is printed out does that mean that i
failed to write good regex no it does
not at all it's failed for one very
important reason and this is the whole
reason why i have this chapter in here
is that
regex when it comes to pattern matching
pattern matching only really works
uh when it comes to regex for single
tokens you can't use regex across
multi-word tokens at least as of spacey
3.1 so what does that mean well it means
that that dash right there in our phone
number is causing all kinds of problems
if we move down to our second example
it's going to be the exact same pattern
a little different let me go ahead and
move this over so you can see it a bit
better
it's going to be regex that looks like
this where we just look for a sequence
of five digits we execute that we find
it just fine and the reason for that is
because this does not have a dash
so regex if you're familiar with it if
you've worked with it it's very powerful
you can do a lot of cool things
when you're going to use this in python
if you're using just the
the standard off the shelf components so
the entity rule or the matcher you're
going to be using this when you want to
match regex to a single token so think
about this if you're looking for
a word that starts off with a capital d
and you want to just grab all words that
start with a capital d
that would be an example of when you
would want to use it in a standard off
the shelf component
but that's not all you can do in spacey
you can use regex to actually capture
multi-word tokens so capture things like
mr deeds so any instance of mr period
space
name a sequence of proper nouns
you can also use it to but yet in order
to do that you have to actually
understand how to add in a custom
component for it and we're going to be
seeing that in just a second as we move
on to chapter nine which is advanced
regex if you're not familiar with regex
at all take a few minutes read chapter
eight i encourage you to do so
because i go over in detail and i talk
about how to actually engage in regex
and python
and its strengths and weaknesses what i
want you to really focus on though and
get away from get from all this is how
to do some really complex multi-word
token matching with regex remember
you're going to want to use regular
expressions when the pattern matching
that you want to do is un independent of
the the lima the pos or any of the
linguistic features that space is going
to use if you're working with linguistic
features you have to use the spacey
pattern
pattern matching things like the morph
the earth the lima things like that but
if your sequence of strings
is not dependent on that so you're
looking for any instance of in this case
we're going to talk about in just a
second a a case where paul is followed
by a capitalized letter and then
a word break
then you're going to want to use regular
expressions because in this case this is
independent
of any linguistic features and regular
expressions allows you to write much
more robust patterns much more quickly
if you know how to use it well and it
allows you to do much more quick uh
robust things within a custom component
and that's going to be where we move to
now
now that we know a little bit about
regex and how it can be implemented in
python let's go ahead and also in spacey
let's go ahead and try and see how we
can get regex to actually find
multi-word tokens for us within spacey
using everything in the spacey framework
so the first thing i'm going to do
to kind of demonstrate all this is i'm
going to import
regex this comes standard with python
and you can import it as re just that
way import re and that's going to import
red jacks i'm going to work from the
textbook
and work with this sample text so this
is paul newman was an american actor but
paul hollywood is a british tv tv host
the name paul is quite common so it's
going to be the text that we work with
throughout this entire chapter
now a regex pattern that i could write
to capture all instances of things like
paul newman and paul hollywood which is
what my goal is could look something
like this i could say
r and make an r string here and say paul
and then i'm going to grab everything
that starts with a capital letter and
then i grab everything until a word
break and that's going to be a pattern
that i can use in regex that what this
formula means is find any instance of
paul proceeded by a in this case a
capital letter until
the actual word break so grab the the
first name paul and then what we can
make a presumption is going to be that
individual's last name in the text a
simple example but one that will
demonstrate our our kind of purpose
right now so how we can do this is we
can create an object called matches and
use regex dot find
iter
we can pass in the pattern and we can
pass in the text so what this is going
to do is it's going to use regex to try
to find this pattern within this text
and then what we can do is we can
iterate over those matches so for match
and matches
we can grab and print off
the match
and we have something that looks like
this
what we're looking at here is what we
would call a regex match object it's got
a couple different components here it's
got a span which tells us the start
character and the end character
and then it has a match and what this
match means is the the actual text
itself so the match here is paul newman
and the match here is paul hollywood so
we've been able to extract the two
entities in the text that begin with
paul
and have a proper last name structured
with a capital letter and we grabbed
everything up until the word break
that's great that's going to be what you
need to know kind of going forward
because what we're going to do now is
we're going to implement this in a
custom spacey pipe but first let's go
through and write the code so that we
can then easily kind of create the pipe
afterwards
so what we need to do is we need to
import
spacey and we also need to say from
spacey.tokens
import span and we're going to be
importing a couple different things as
we move forward because we're going to
see that we're going to make a couple
mistakes intentionally i'm going to show
you how to kind of address these common
mistakes that might surface in trying to
do something like this
so once we've imported those two things
we can start actually writing out our
code again we're going to stick with the
exact same text and again we're going to
stick with the exact same pattern that
we've got stored in memory up up above
so we need to do now is we need to
create a blank spacey object or sorry a
blank spacey pipeline that we can kind
of put all this information into
and for right now what we're going to do
is we're just going to
kind of go through and look at these
individual entities
so again we're going to create the doc
object which is going to be equal to nlp
text and this is not going to be
necessary for right now but i'm
establishing a kind of a consistent
workflow for us and you're going to see
how we kind of take all this and
implement it inside of a pipeline so
we're going to say original ends is
equal to list
doc.ins now in this scenario there's not
going to be any entities because we
don't have an nar or an entity ruler in
our blank spacey pipeline
what we're going to do next is we're
going to create something called an nwt
and
and that's going to stand for multi-word
token entity
you can name this whatever you like this
is just what i kind of stick to
and then we're going to do and this is
straight from the spacey documentation
we're going to say from match and
re.find it the same thing that we saw
above
pattern
doc.text so what this is going to do is
it's going to take that doc object
look at it as raw text because remember
the doc object is a container that
doesn't actually have raw text in it
until you actually call the dot text
attribute
and then our goal is for each of these
things we're going to look and call in
this span so we're going to say is start
and the end is equal to match dot span
so what we're doing here is we're going
in and grabbing the span attribute and
we're grabbing these two components the
start and the end but we have a problem
these are character spans remember the
doc object works on a token level so
we've got to kind of figure out a way to
reverse engineer this almost to actually
get this into a spacey form fortunately
the doc object also has an attribute
called character span
so what we can do is we can say the span
is equal to doc dot char span
start and end so what this is going to
do is it's going to print off
essentially for us let's go ahead and do
that it would print off for us where we
were to actually have an entity here
it would print off for us as we can see
paul newman and paul hollywood
so what we need to do now is we need to
get
this span
into our entities
so what we can do is instead of printing
things off we can say if
span is not none because in some
instance instances this will be the case
you're going to say nwt
ins dot append
you're going to append a tuple here
span.start
span.end
span span.text so this is going to be
the start the end and the text itself
and once we've done that we've managed
to get our multi-word tokens into
a list that looks like this
start
end
paul newman paul hollywood and notice
that our span.start
is aligning not with
a character span now
it's rather aligning with a token span
so what we've done is we've taken this
character span here and been able to
find out where they start and end within
the the token sequence so we have zero
and two so paul newman won this was the
zero index it goes up until the second
index so it grabs index token 0 and
token 1 and we've done the same thing
with paul hollywood now that we've got
that data we can actually start to
inject these entities into
our original entities so let's go
through and do that right now
so we can do once we've got these things
appended to this list we can start
injecting them into our original
entities so we can say for end
in
mwt ins
what we want to do is we want to say the
start the end and the name is equal to
end because this is going to correspond
to the tuple the start the end and the
entity text
now what we can do is we can say per in
so this is going to be the individual
end we're going to create a span object
in spacey
it's going to look like this so a
capital s here remember we imported it
right up here this is where we're going
to be working with the span class
and this is going to create for us a
span object that we can now safely
inject into the spacey doc.ins list so
we can say doc start
and
label and this is going to be the label
that we want to actually assign it and
this is going to be person in this case
because these are all people what we can
do now is we can go through
and say
doc
we can inject this into the original
ends
original ends
dot append and we're going to append the
per end which is going to be this span
object
and finally what we can say is doc dot
ins is equal to
original ins kind of like what we saw
just a few moments ago
and let's go ahead and print off
we've got our entities right there were
we to do this up here when we first kind
of create the doc object you'll see
nothing an empty list but now what we've
been able to do is inject these into the
doc object the doc.ins attribute and we
can say for int and doc.ins
just like everything else end.text and
dot label
and because we converted it into a span
we were able to inject it into the
entity
attribute from the doc object kind of
natively so that spacey can actually
understand it so what can we do with
this well one of the things that we
could do is we can use the knowledge
that we just acquired about custom
components and build a custom component
around all of this so how might we do
that
well let's go through and try it out
the first thing that we need to do is we
need to import our language class so
remember from a few moments ago whenever
you need to work with a custom component
you need to say from spacey
dot language
import
language with a capital l what we're
going to do now is we're going to take
the code that we just wrote and we're
going to try to convert that into an
actual custom pipe that can fit inside
of our pipeline as kind of our own
custom entity ruler if you will
so what we're going to do now is we're
going to call this
language.com
and we're going to call this um let's
call this paul nar something not too not
too clever but kind of very descriptive
we're going to call this paul ner and
this is going to take that single doc
object because remember this pipe needs
to receive the doc object and do stuff
to it so what we can do is we can take
all this code that we just wrote
from here down
and paste it
into our function
and what we have is the ability now to
implement this as a custom pipe
we don't need to do this because we
don't want to print things off
but here we're going to return the doc
object so what we have now is a custom
kind of entity ruler that uses regex
across multiple tokens if you want to
use regex in spacey across multiple
tokens as of spacey 3.1 this is the only
way to implement this so now we can take
this pipe
and we can actually
add it to a blank custom model so let's
make a new nlp call this nlp2 is equal
to spacey.blank
and we're going to create a blank
english model
nlp2 dot add
pipe
we're going to add in paul ner
and now we see that we've actually
created that successfully so we have one
pipe kind of sitting in all of this now
what we can do is we can go through and
we need to probably add in our pattern
as well here just for good practice
because this should be stored somewhat
adjacent i like to sometimes to keep it
up here when i'm doing this but you can
also keep it kind of inside of the
function itself
let's go ahead and just kind of save
that and we're going to rerun this
cool
now what we can do is we can say doc 2
is equal to nlp2 we're going to go over
that exact same text
and we're going to print off our
doc2.ins
and we've now managed to implement that
as a custom spacey pipe but we've got
one big problem
let's say
just hypothetically
we wanted to also kind of work in
really a another
kind of
uh
something into our actual pipeline we
wanted this pipeline to sit on top of
maybe an existing spacey model and for
whatever reason we don't want paul
hollywood
to have that title we wanted to have the
title
maybe we want to just kind of keep paul
hollywood as a person but we also want
to find maybe
other cinema style
entities so we're going to create
another
entity here instead of all this that's
going to be something like let's go
ahead and make a new
a new container down here a new
component down here
we're going to just look for any
instance of hollywood
and we're going to call that the word
the label of cinema so i want to
demonstrate this because this is going
to show you something that you are going
to encounter when you try to implement
this in the real world and i'm going to
show you how to kind of address the
problem that you're going to encounter
so if we had a component that looked
like this now it's going to look for
just an instances of hollywood and let's
call this holly
cinema
nar
and change this here as well
what we can do now is go ahead and load
that up into memory so we've got this
new component called cinema ner
and just like before we're going to
create nlp three now this is going to be
spacey.load
n core web
sm
and so what this
is going to do is it's going to load up
the spacey small model
nlp3.add
pipe
and it's going to be the what did i call
this again the cinema
ner
and if we were to go through and add
that and create a new object called doc3
make that equal to
nlp3 text
we're going to get this error and this
is a common error and if you google it
you'll eventually find the right answer
i'm just going to give it to you right
now so what this is telling you is that
there are spans that overlap
that don't actually work because um one
of the spans
for cinema is hollywood and the small
model is extracting not only that
hollywood as a cinema but it's also
extracting paul of hollywood as part of
a longer token so what's happened here
is we're trying to assign a span
to two of the same tokens and that
doesn't work in spacey it'll break
so what can you do well a common method
of solving this issue is to work with
the filter spans from the spacey.util
let's go ahead and do this right now so
we can say from spacey.util
import filter spans what filter spans
allows for you to do is to actually
filter out
all of the uh the spans that are being
identified so what we can do is we can
say at this stage
before you get to the doc.ns you can say
filtered is equal to
filter
spans original ends so what does this do
well what this does is it goes through
and looks at all of the different start
and end sections from all of your
entities and if there is ever an
instance where there is a an overlap of
tokens so
8 to 10 and 9 to 10
premises and priority is going to be
given to the longer token so we can do
is we can set this now to filtered and
it helps if you call it correctly
filtered there we go
we can set that to filtered instead of
the original entities go ahead and save
that we're going to add this again
and we're going to do doc3 and we're
going to save for int and doc3.ends
print and dot text and end dot label
and if we've done this correctly we're
not going to see
the
cinema label come out at all because
paula hollywood is a longer token
than
just hollywood so what we've done is
we've told spacey give
primacy to the longer tokens and assign
that label by filtering out the tokens
you can prevent that air from ever
surfacing but this is a very common
thing that you're going to have to
implement sometimes regex really is the
easiest way to inject and do pattern
matching in the entity
okay so here's the scenario that we have
before us in order to make this live
this kind of live coding and applied
spacey a little bit more interesting
imagine in this scenario we have a
client and the client is a stock broker
somebody who's interested in investing
and what they want to be able to do is
look at news articles like those coming
out of reuters and they want to find the
news articles that are the most relevant
to what they need to actually search for
and read for the day so they want to
find the ones that deal with their their
personal stocks their holdings or maybe
their um the specific index that they're
actually interested in so what this
client wants is a way to use spacey to
automatically find all companies
referenced within a text
all stocks referenced within a text
and all indexes referenced with the next
text and maybe even some stock exchanges
as well now on the the actual textbook
if you go through to this chapter which
is number 10 you're going to find all
the kind of solutions laid out for you
what i'm going to do throughout the next
30 or 40 minutes is kind of walk through
how i
might solve this problem at least on the
surface this is going to be a
rudimentary solution that demonstrates
the power of spacey and how you can
apply it in a very short period of time
to do some pretty custom tasks such as
financial analysis with that structured
data that you've extracted you can then
do any number of things what we're going
to start off with though is importing
spacey
and importing pandas
as pd if you're not familiar with pandas
i've got a whole tutorial series on that
on my channel python tutorials for
digital humanities even though it has
digital humanities in the title it's for
kind of everyone
but go through if you're not familiar
with pandas and check that out you're
not really going to need it for
for this video here you're going to just
need to understand that i'm using pandas
to access and grab the data that i need
from a couple csv files or comma
separated value files that i have
so the first thing that we need to do is
we need to create what's known as a
pandas data frame
this is going to be equal to pd
dot read csv and i actually have these
stored in the data subfolder in the repo
you have free access to these they're
little tiny data sets that i cultivated
pretty quickly they're not perfect but
they're good enough for our purposes and
we're going to use the separator keyword
argument which is going to say to
separate everything out by
tab because these are tsv files tab
separated value files and we have
something that looks like this so what
this stocks.tsv file is is it's all the
symbols company names industry and
market caps for i think it's around 5
700 different stocks 5879
and so what we're going to use this for
is as a way to start working into an
entity ruler
all these different symbols and company
names what we want to do is we want to
use these symbols to work into a model
as a way to grab stocks that might be
referenced and you can already probably
start to see a problem with this capital
a here we're going to get to that in a
little bit and we want to grab all the
company names so we can maybe create two
different entity types from this data
set
stock
and company
so let's go through and make these intel
lists so they're a little bit warm
so let's go through and make these into
lists so they're a little bit more
manageable
what we need to do is we need to create
a list of symbols and that's going to be
equal to df.symbol.2
list this is a great way to do it in
pandas so you can kind of easily convert
all these different columns into
different lists that you can work with
in python so companies is going to be
equal to df dot
company and name i believe the name was
to list and just to demonstrate how this
works let's print off symbols we're
going to print up to 10
and you can kind of see we've managed to
take these columns now and kind of build
them into a simple python list
so what can we do with that well one of
the things that we can do is we can use
that information to start cultivating an
entity ruler but remember we want more
things than just one or two kind of n i
want to do ruler we don't just want
stocks and we don't just want companies
we also want things like indexes we're
going to get to that in just a second
though for right now let's try to work
these two things into an entity ruler
how might we go about doing that
well as you might expect we're going to
create a fairly simple entity ruler so
we're going to say is nlp is going to be
equal to spacey.blank we don't need a
lot of fancy features here we're just
going to have a blank model that's just
going to host host and
single entity ruler that's going to be
equal to nlp dot add
underscore pipe and this is going to be
entity ruler
and now what we need to do is we need to
come up with a way to go through all of
these different symbols
and add them in so we can say for symbol
and symbols we want to say patterns dot
append and we're going to make a an
empty list of patterns up here
and what we're going to append is that
dictionary that you met when we talked
about the entity ruler and i believe it
was chapter 5 yeah
and what this is going to have are two
things label which is going to
correspond to stock in this case
and it's going to have a
pattern
and that's going to correspond to the
pattern of the symbol so we're going to
say symbol
and what that lets us do is kind of go
through and easily create and add these
patterns in and we can do the same thing
for company remember it's never a good
idea to copy and paste in your code i am
simply doing it for demonstration
purposes right now this is not polish
code by any stretch of the imagination
and what we can do here now is we can do
the same thing loop over the different
companies
and add each company in so what this is
doing is it's creating a large list of
different patterns that the entity ruler
will use to then go through and as we
create the a doc object over that sample
reuters text i just showed you a second
ago
which we should probably just go ahead
and pull up right now i'm going to copy
and paste it straight from the textbook
let's go ahead and execute that cell
and we're going to add in this text here
it is a little lengthy but it'll be all
right and what we're going to do now is
we're going to iterate over it create a
doc object to iterate over all of that
and our goal here is going to be able to
say for int and doc.ends we want to have
extracted all of these different
entities so we can say
print off int dot text and dot label
and let's see if we succeeded
and we have to add in our patterns to
our entity ruler so remember we can do
this by saying ruler.add
patterns
patterns there we go
that's what this error actually means
and now when we do it we see that we've
been able to extract
uh apple as a company apple as a company
nasdaq everything's looking pretty good
but i notice really quickly that i
wasn't actually able to extract
apple as a stock and i've also got
another problem i've extracted to
the lowercase two as a stock as well why
have these two things are as a company
well it turns out in our data set we've
got two two that is a company name
that's almost always going to be a false
positive and we know that that kind of
thing might be better off worked into a
machine learning model
for right now though we're going to work
under the presumption that any time we
encounter this kind of obscure company
two as a lower case it's going to be a
false positive i also have another
problem i know for a fact that apple the
stock is referenced within this text to
make it a little easier let's see it
right here and notice that it didn't
find it to make this a little easier to
display let's go ahead and display what
we're looking at as
displacy render so what we can do is we
can use that displacy render that we met
a little bit ago in this video
so in order to import this if you
remember we need to say
from spacey
import displacy
and that's going to allow us to actually
display our entities let's go ahead and
put this however
on a different cell just so we don't
have to execute that every time and
we're going to say
a display see
dot render and we're going to just
render the doc object with the style
that's equal to ent
and we can see that we've got our text
now popping out with our things labeled
and you can see pretty quickly where
we've made some mistakes where we need
to incorporate some things into our
entity ruler so for example if i'm
scrolling through this is gray a little
ugly we can change the colors that's
beyond the scope of this video though
but let's keep on going down we notice
that we have apple
dot io and yet this has been missed by
our entity ruler why has this been
missed well
spacey
as a tokenizer is seeing this as a
single
token so apple dot
o the letter o capital letter o
why is that well i i didn't know about
this but apparently it does it has to
deal with kind of the way in which uh
stock indices are i think it's on the
nasdaq kind of structure things so what
can we do well we've got a couple
different options here i know that these
go through all different letters from a
to z so we can either work with the
string library or what we can do is we
can import a a quick list that i've
already written out of all the different
letters of the alphabet and iterate
through those
with our ruler up here
let's go ahead and add these letters
right there and we can kind of iterate
through those and whenever a stock kind
of pops out
with that kind of symbol
plus any occurrence where it's got a
period followed by a letter in those
scenarios we want that to be flagged as
a stock as well so what we can do is we
can add in another thing right here add
in another pattern and this is now going
to be symbol
plus we're going to add an f string
right here a formatted string
any occurrence of l
we can set up a loop to say
for l and letters
do this
what this is going to allow us to do
is to look for any instance where there
is
a symbol
followed by a period followed by
one of these capitalized letters that i
just copied and pasted in so if we do
that we can execute that cell
and we can scroll down and we can now do
the exact same thing that we just did a
second ago
and actually display this
and now we're finding these stocks
highlighted as stock so we're
successfully getting these stocks and
extracting them we've got a few
different things that our client wants
to also extract though they don't want
to just extract companies and they don't
want to just extract
stock and they want to also extract
stock exchanges and indexes but we have
one other problem let me go ahead and
get rid of this as the display mode and
switch back to just our set of entities
because it's a little easier to read for
this example
we've got another problem and we see we
have a couple other stocks popping out
we now know that kroger
stock is here the nio dot in stock is in
this text as well now we're starting to
see a greater degree of specificity
for right now i'm going to include two
as a set of a stop a technical term
would be like a stop board something
that i don't want to be included into
the model so i'm gonna make a list of
stops
and we're just gonna include two in that
and we're gonna save for company and
companies do all this
if
company
not in stops we want this to occur what
this means now is that our our pipeline
while going through and having all of
these different things all these
different rules it's also going to have
another rule that looks to see if
there's a stop or if this company name
is this stop and if it is then we want
it to just kind of skip over and ignore
it
and if we go through we notice that now
we've successfully eliminated this what
we would presume to be a consistent
false positive something that's going to
come up again and again as a false
positive
great so we've been able to to get this
where it works now pretty well
what i also want to work into this model
if you remember though are things like
indexes fortunately i've also provided
for us a list of all different indexes
that are available from
i believe it's everything like the dow
jones there's about 13 or 14 of them
let's go ahead and import those up above
and let's do that right here in this
cell so it kind of goes in sequential
order and it falls better with the
textbook too so it's a new data frame
object this is going to be equal to
pd.read
csv we're going to read in that data
file that i've given us and that's going
to be the indexes.tsv
with a separator that's equal to a tab
let's see what that looks like
and this is what it looks like so all
these different indices now i know i'm
going to have a problem right out of the
gate and that's going to be that
sometimes you're going to see things
referenced as s p 500 i don't know a lot
about finances but i know that you don't
always see it as s p 500 index
but i do think that these index symbols
are also going to be useful so like i
did before i'm going to convert these
things into a list so it's a little
easier for me to work with in a for loop
and i'm going to say
indexes
is equal to df2
dot index
name so grabbing that column
to list
and index symbols
is equal to df2 dot index symbol
dot to list and both of these are going
to be different and uh they're both
going to have the same exact
entity label which is going to be a an
index and let's let's go ahead and
iterate over these
and add them in as well so i'm going to
go ahead and do that right now
for index
and indexes
we want this label to be index
we want this to be index here
so that's going to allow us to kind of
go through and grab all those and we
want to do the same thing with index
symbols
keep these a little separated here index
symbols
and that allows for us to do that and
let's go ahead and without making any
adjustments let's see let's see how this
does with these new patterns that we've
added in and because we've already got
this text loaded into memory i'm gonna
go ahead and put this right here doc is
gonna be equal to uh nlp text
for int and doc dot ends
print off and dot text
and dot label
and we can kind of go through and we're
actually now able to extract some
indexes and i believe when i was looking
at this text really quickly though i
noticed that there was one instance at
least where
we had not only the index referenced but
also
a name like s p 500 right here s p 500
notice that it isn't found because it
doesn't have the name index after it and
notice also that none of our
our symbols are being found because they
all seem to be preceded by a dot so in
this case a dot j a d j i
and so that's something else that i have
to work into this model and the list
i've gave the data set that's not there
so i need to collect a list of these
different names and work those into an
entity ruler as well but for right now
let's ignore that and focus on including
this s p 500 so how can i get the s p
500 in there from the list i already
gave it well what i can do is i can say
okay
so under these indices not only do i
want to add that specific pattern let's
go ahead and break these things up into
different words and so i'm going to have
the words is equal to index dot split
and then i'm going to make a presumption
that the the first two words so the s p
500 the s p 400 are sometimes going to
be referenced by themselves so what i
want to do is i want to work that into
the model as well
and i want to say
we're going to say patterns.append
copy this as well
we can say something like uh
dot join
words
up until the second index
and let's go ahead and work that into
our model in our patterns our pipeline
and print off our
nlp again and you'll find that we've now
been able to capture
things like snp 500 that aren't
proceeded by the word index and we see
that we in fact have s p 500 is now
popping out time and again that's
fantastic i'm pretty happy with that now
we're we're getting a deeper sense of
what this text is about without actually
having to read it we know that it's
going to deal heavily with apple and we
know that it's also going to
tangentially deal with some of these
other things as
well but i also want to include into
this into this pipeline
the ability for the entity ruler to not
just find these things but i also wanted
to be able to find different stock
exchanges so i've got a list i
cultivated for different stock exchanges
which are things like nyse things like
that so i can say ds
3 is going to be equal to
pd.read csv
data backslash stock exchanges
dot tsv
and then the separator is going to be
again a tab
and let's take a look at what this looks
like
exchanges there we go
there we are
and we have something that looks like
this a pretty a pretty large csv file
tsv file sorry
that's got a bunch of different rows the
ones i'm most interested in well there's
a couple actually i'm interested in
specifically the google prefix and this
description the description has the
actual name and the prefix has this
really nice abbreviation that i've seen
pop out a few different times such as
nasdaq here
if we keep on going down we would see
different things as well nyse these are
kind of different stock
exchanges so let's pop back down here
and let's go ahead and convert those two
things into individual
lists as well so we're going to say
exchanges it's going to be equal to df3
dot iso mic
dot to list
and then i'm also going to grab df3 dot
uh sorry google
and i have to do this as a dictionary
because it's uh the way the data sets
cultivated it's got a space in the
middle this is a common problem that you
run into
and then i also want to
know grab all of these exchanges as well
so i'm going to say
also on top of that
df3 dot
description
dot 2 list so i'm making a
large list exchanges
and i get this here because it says
google prefix isn't an actual thing and
in fact it's prefix with an i
and now we actually are able to get all
these things
extracted so what i want to do now
is i want to work all these different
symbols and descriptions into
into the model as well or into the
pipeline as well so i can say for
for e and exchanges
i want to say patterns
dot append
and i want to do a label that's going to
be let's do stock
exchange
and then the next thing i want to do is
a pattern and that's going to be equal
to in this case e as we're going to see
this is not adequate enough we need to
do a few different things to really kind
of work this out but it's going to be
good enough to at least get started
and it's going to take it just a second
and the main thing that's happening
right now are these different for loops
so if we keep on going down we now see
that we were able to extract the nyse
stock exchange so we've not only been
able to work into a pipeline in a very
short order maybe about 20 30 minutes
we've been able to work into a pipeline
all of these different things that are
coming out we do however see a couple
problems and this is where i'm going to
leave it though because you've got the
basic mechanics down now comes time for
you being a domain expert to work out
and come up with rules to solve some of
these problems nasdaq is not a company
so there's a problem with the data set
or
nasdaq is listed as a company name in
one of the data sets uh we need to work
that out where nasdaq is never
referenced as a company
we have the s p and uh is now being
coming out correctly as s p 500 there
might be instances where just s p is
referenced which i think in that context
would probably be the s p 500 but
nevertheless we've been able to actually
extract these things sometimes the s
these
the dow jones industrial average average
might just be referenced to dow jones so
this index might just be these first two
words i know that's a common occurrence
we've also seen that we weren't able to
extract some of those things that were a
period followed by a symbol
that referenced the actual index itself
nevertheless this is a really good
starting point and you can see how just
in a few minutes you're able to generate
this thing that can extract information
from unstructured text at the end of the
day like i said in the introduction to
this entire video that's one of the
essential tasks of nlp
designing this and implementing it is
pretty quick and easy
perfecting it is where the time really
is to get this financial analysis
entity rule working really well where it
has almost no false positives and
almost never misses a true
a true positive
it would take maybe a few more hours of
just some kind of working and eventually
there are certain things you might find
that would work better in a machine
learning model nevertheless you can see
the degree to which rules based
approaches in spacey can really
accomplish some pretty robust tasks with
minimal minimal amount of code so long
as you have access to or have already
cultivated the data sets required
thank you so much for watching this
video series on spacey an introduction
to basic concepts of natural language
processing linguistic annotations in
spacey vectors pipelines and kind of
rules based spacey if you've enjoyed
this video please like and subscribe
down below and if you've also found this
video useful consider joining me on my
channel python tutorials for digital
humanities if you have liked this and
found this video useful i'm envisioning
a second part to this video where i go
over the machine learning aspects of
spacey if you're interested in that let
me know in the comments down below and
i'll make a second video that
corresponds to this one
thank you for watching and have a great
day